this is a great collection yeah this is
these are all from plastisol look even
the sunglasses come off on
wow yeah it's pretty dope
john wick john wick and his pitbull bull
awesome yeah i got kanye bruce lee
but the glasses are biggies i know well
this guy's amazing
shout out to fong from plasticile he
makes some dope [ __ ]
yeah he's amazing but not as amazing as
that [ __ ] you did in the green room man
david just did uh some card wizardry
that uh
it's one thing that you see when you see
that [ __ ] on tv like if i was there i'd
see some [ __ ] i know what's going on
but when you see it in real life you're
like what is happening here
yeah it's way better like uh in person
than
oh yeah well at the end i don't give
anything away but the end
literally a man is holding one of his
wrists and
another guy's holding the other wrist
and he still does the card trick and we
still can't figure out what happened
when did you get started how old were
you um so i i was about five years old
when i
started playing with cards but i didn't
know what what they were
for really so i just had a deck of cards
that i carried everywhere
but i liked the way it felt you know
just like it felt like something cool
so eventually a librarian was like oh we
got this like magic
self-working card trick booking do you
want to learn something
and i was like yeah of course
and she shows me the that silly
self-working mathematical trick that's a
long process to do but it's still a cool
outcome like oh i found your card right
right
and my mother i used to wait for her at
the library and she'd come get me when
she was done
and when she came i said can i show you
this trick and the librarian was excited
for me to do it to her
which is what i do to my friends kids i
teach them a trick and make them really
good at it and i'm so excited to see
them do it you know
right okay so my mother comes and i do
the trick
and my mom goes crazy like it was
like it was the best thing ever and so
like
but that began the love of wanting to
learn new tricks because i wanted to
keep making her
you know react you know happier so that
was
basically the fundamental start of it
and then also
she would take me to coney island all
the time and um you know
on the side on the boardwalk there
there's those weird
freak show performers stuff so i'd watch
those guys and it to me it was all like
magical so that that was kind of the
beginning of
it so isn't it funny how one positive
experience when you're young
can ignite this chain of events yeah
that changes your whole life
by the way and also so then the
librarian when i would come
she would give me books and i would
start looking at that little magic
section that was between like
games and puzzles i thought i always
wished magic would be like not there
like it should be like an art or so you
know just
it was always like when you want a magic
book it's always like that silly like
kids jokey thing but there's like so
in that section i pulled out a book
and i was like six years old and i see a
guy
chained to the side of a building
staring out looking like
death is upon him and that was her
dealing and i didn't know anything about
what that all meant i looked through the
pictures and he was hanging upside down
and stuff like that
but when i went to sleep i would have
these dreams of this guy chained to the
side of a building
and that began my curiosity and love of
of houdini and then that began my
curiosity of like
not just like the magic trick stuff but
like
this stuff that's to me it's more like
real
yeah how do those two worlds collide
because
some of the things you're doing they're
they're just insane
endurance and mental exercises
and then other things you're doing are
what you would consider
magic right so so i love both separately
like independently like i always love
like i had a
karate teacher at the ymca that used to
make us all run barefoot in the snow in
the winter in brooklyn
and all the kids were like you know
we're young we're like six seven and all
the kids like ah you know i'm afraid
they were gonna cut their feet on glass
whatever
and i would run in it and i felt like i
could do this
because i wasn't good at other things
physically like i was wanting my feet
turned in and stuff like that
so i felt like this i could do these
things so then
i learned how to hold my breath and the
reason i learned to hold my breath was
simply because i was on the swim team at
the y also
and the other kids would swim back and
forth and they'd destroy me because my
feet didn't function perfectly well
and what i learned is that if i didn't
breathe if i just swam
it would save me time because i didn't
have to move my head dip it out and you
know
right so i would just swim and the coach
would yell at me but suddenly i was
no longer in last place i was like now
second and sometimes
first and that began my like oh god
you can actually do what the coach
doesn't think is possible you could swim
there and back without breathing
and then the older kids would come to
see me do that and i would like
challenge them i'd be like
um let's see you could stay under the
longest and you can go
up and down five times i didn't
understand the physiology of it that
like going up and down doesn't help it's
more
effective to just sit through the pain
and just kind of chill
but i would just sit there and they'd go
up and come back down
which makes it worse that they'd be out
and i just doesn't make it worse
because uh the breath holding thing is
all about like a co2 buildup in your
bloodstream and it's about
a tolerance level to it so if you relax
and efficiently keep your oxygen
and not make this co2 build up more
extreme you can actually hold more
efficiently
so when you have that feeling everybody
has that feeling where you need to
breathe
that's it's not an o2 deprivation it's a
trigger from a co2 buildup which is
giving you an alert that
for example in 20 minutes from now
you will not recover and i didn't
believe that either some
a magician friend of mine who's amazing
um
and one of my like heroes in life
uh he he told me a story as i was doing
like buried alive i was saying he said
you know
you know the navy seals you know they
black them out under water
so they're not afraid of drowning and
i'm like that can't
no way like because it seems so abstract
to me you know
so but it stuck in my brain and then
when i wanted to do the water tank stunt
and i started learning about free diving
and stuff like that
i suddenly realized blacking out is
pretty straightforward like you black
out and then you get your head above the
water and if you're supervised you're
fine
so when i went to san diego with the
seals i watched what they do and i
actually did it but i didn't black out
it
went back and forth a few times and
pulled but they have that viewing pool
and they rope the seals up to some 45
pound weights and they have to walk
across the bottom of the pool and the
instructors are swimming above them
and when this when the seals black out
they cut the rope bring them up to the
top
and they're fine but what that teaches
you is that you do not need to worry
about being underwater because if you're
with a team and you but by the way
nobody should try this you know there is
extreme dangers to shall water blackouts
which lead to death but if you are
in somebody that's training and you have
a team and you want to push it
as soon as you black out it's like
getting knocked out it's it's but it
feels better it's not like getting
knocked out with a punch it's like
you're getting
choked it's your four no but no yeah but
choked out as euphoric
right yeah exactly except this one's
even better and then you have all these
dreams no
no it makes it sound exciting that part
of it
whenever i wake up from a blackout i'm
like whoa
that's how people wake up when they get
choked out really the same yeah when
people get choked out they wake up
almost like they were dreaming
like sometimes they think they're at a
disco yeah yeah yeah it's amazing and
they're like what
yeah wow and
it's not the best thing in the world for
you but it's way better for you than
getting knocked unconscious
yeah yeah it chokes the head yeah choked
out is just a it just
shuts off the blood to the brain right
and the brain shuts off yeah and then it
comes back online but there's no trauma
right yeah but it's not yeah so it's
like a [ __ ] yeah
blacking out under the blacking out
underwater thing probably not a good
idea to do too many times though right
no you could do it i mean i've blacked
out underwater a lot i mean
by the way so okay times i don't know
like
between 20 to 30. i mean i have like wow
by the way you guys were talking about
me on the thing about the breath hold
thing yeah so
yeah one time i went 20 minutes and two
seconds i almost did what you were
talking about the length of a show but i
did 20 minutes in two seconds and i had
telemetry there and i had pulmonary
experts and everything like that
and my heart rate dropped to eight beats
per minute
holy [ __ ] and they pulled me up because
they were freaked out
that's why you were dying yeah but back
to what i'm saying is
the reason besides the navy seal story
that i knew that it was
it made sense was because you hear about
the kids in the news like in 1984 or
whatever it was a kid was under an icy
river for 45 minutes
yeah with nothing
blacked out unconscious underwater for
45 minutes
they rescue him out pull him back
recover him in full recovery
so there's something that the body does
that we don't understand
it but if you actualize so because he
blacked out and because it was so cold
the blood shunting occurred we're all
like the same as when you get cold the
blood rushes away from the extremities
and protects the vital organs
and because he didn't inhale the water
because he was
completely out of it when they recovered
him they didn't even have to get water
out of his lungs and he was perfectly
fine
wow so but but that just shows you that
there's like a
certain levels of of what the body can
tolerate that
we have no idea so you
in in learning how to swim and learning
how to go all the way back and forth and
holding your breath this
started this idea of holding your breath
for an extreme long period of time like
what had been the record
before you would like 20 minutes and how
many seconds two seconds yeah that's
what you did
yeah but that's what happened what have
you done before that would have been
your record okay so when i was a kid i
heard
as i start reading about houdini his
like proud record of his lifetime and
he's the underwater escape
king for a hundred years ago and he had
he was around the best swimmers and he
had access
and he got up to three and a half
minutes so by the time i was like a
teenage early teenager i got to three
and a half minutes and did you think
that that was a barrier that couldn't be
crossed
well i came i blacked out as i came out
but i didn't know what that all meant
right so i blacked out was that so i was
like okay
that 330 seems like the edge
but then when i started working on the
actual concept of like how long can you
hold your breath for then i started
looking into it i'm like oh wow there's
like people that can do five minutes six
minutes seven minutes
and then there was a hypothetical record
of um
of uh a hypothetical
13-minute record but no evidence of it
and that was on pure02
so it was a hypothetical bureau two
record of 13. when you say on
too what's your process that flushes
everything out so you start
pure o2 yeah hold on to pure too yeah
and yeah i purge really hard on pure
tusa
which is like hypervent which gets rid
of the co2 and gives you more room for
oxygen
and by the way i just went up to 25 000
feet
in an airplane ascending at 500 feet per
minute
doors open and everything no oxygen and
i was with
luke akins who jumped from 25 000 feet
with no parachute landed in that he was
with me and two other
the pilot and two other guys we just
right under 25 those are 24 7 whatever
and um he's i said let's see who goes
hypoxic
first right so no no but we have no but
you have to take the ox the o2
you have to take the o2 monitors you
have to be on the right
so and i was already in a hypobaric
chamber with the fa
at oklahoma city and i started purging
just to see what it would do
and my levels my oxygen levels shot up
which nobody believes is possible
so i get into the airplane and we put
the monitors on and everybody's around
the same i was actually lower than luke
i was
like at 90 whatever 596. he was at like
97 he's like oh i'm going to go you know
joking with me
and as soon as we cross 15 000 feet
his slowly is starting to come down and
i start doing the breathing technique
the
purging out like i said right my oxygen
levels
and we filmed all this shot up to 98 and
then 99
is i went up to 23 plus
thousand feet now these guys think i'm a
magician so they're like yeah uh-huh
like fake news that's what he wrote on
the paper next to the levels because he
was recording it
so i took his monitor off of his finger
and he took mine i put his monitor on my
finger
put mine on his bang his was dropping
around 70 and mine was 98.99
then i switch with day i switch with
everybody on the plane and the oxygen
levels with the breathing all the way up
to that altitude
and i'm not recommending this because i
haven't tested enough and but
they did stay up at 98.99
and so my evidence for that was
you hear about all the sherpas that go
up to the top of everest
up to 29 000 feet and they're not
bringing oxygen i get it they're
acclimating six but they're still
at 29 plus thousand feet so they're
doing
something that's allowing them to rewire
their ability to not go hypoxic
so this breathing technique you're
essentially exhaling more than you're
breathing in so you're breathing a small
amount in
and then i fill up everything for
full but i mean full like top to bottom
hold for a second and then
exhale slowly and i like for example if
when
when we're done here if you have 20
minutes i'll get you up to a four and a
half minute breath hold
in 20 minutes and this is just through
these breathing techniques yeah
when we're done with this i'll show you
how to do it and you will get up to four
plus minutes for sure and how did you
so you you've learned that you could go
three and a half minutes or three
minutes plus right and yeah and
and blackout and then how did you have
it in your head
that you were going to eventually get to
20 minutes okay so
you really ought to hear all that yeah
yeah it's a long i'll go let's go
okay and i forget where i'm going okay
it's okay so you might have to remind me
where we're going
yeah okay i just want to know the
process because okay yeah but it's a
little
magician by trade well but first of all
i like houdini so i
love magic but i like houdini and
houdini was like king of cards as well
but he's a guy that's doing real things
right and then i like guys that are like
as i go i go to the museum of
broadcasting because there was no
youtube or whatever so i'd look at like
these magic you search magic
and i'd find like guys that would like
drink a gallon
of water drink a liter of kerosene he
would float all the kerosene on top of
the water
and then he would spit out kerosene out
of his mouth look like a human dragon
and then put the fire out with a gallon
of water
so it's that it is magic but it's
it's art it's mind-blowing it's an art
it's a performance p
it's not like it's incredible now look
there's guys that are
card guys that are like that also like
lots lots of people i love and
they do the cards in a way that's like
but but
that act to me was what pressed a button
it was like
whoa like how is he converting his body
to do a trick
and there's a guy today performing
called stevie star who's called the
human regurgitator but
he swallows crazy things like so
he combines magic with his abilities so
like he went on jay leno or one yeah i
think it was leonard carson
he takes you know the little film
canisters that used to drink
so he puts a film canister empty
closes it for the you know you get the
35 and then he goes
and then he swallows it so it's in it's
yeah it's gone
and he goes like that's gone then he
would take
a bunch of water drink that and then
there'd be a cup with a goldfish in it
drinks the cup and the goldfish and then
you have jay leno sign the cap
the the lid thing to the thing with a
piece of tape and sign it
right then he'd take that and go now
everything is gone
then he does these weird sounds and
movements which is part of his show
right and then he brings it up spits it
out
and the film canister is sealed
and it is the water and the fish and
it's sealed with the signature
so to me that's like the coolest magic
because your take
because when you see a trick you know
like oh that's cool but it's a trick so
it's like you're being removed from
being able to like
absorb but when you see somewhere
somebody's doing something crazy and it
seems like a trick but it's also like
wait this is real
because he's really doing this it's just
way more exciting you know
i understand i understand it's just
do you know how he did that one
obviously yeah i talked to him yeah i
talked to him all the time
yeah i love steve stevie star you know
how it was done
but you can't reveal that right yeah he
and and okay there's another guy tom
mullika who
he passed away and he was this guy he's
the first magician ever so he did a
simple card trick and i was crying
i was like in tears i was like oh my god
but
he and he passed away and i filmed that
and and he's
i'm gonna do a really amazing piece
about him because he is incredible but
he also was on like uh johnny carson
shows what he would do is he would take
a pack of cigarettes
throw them into his mouth one at a time
light them on fire
bring them back out and then throw them
into his mouth one time eat all the
cigarettes
yes there he is so
and watch he eats the cigarettes wow
that's great how fast they pulled that
up
it's not day it's young jamie oh it's
you he's a wizard yeah
he's a wizard of mine look so he takes
by the way this act killed him so that's
how dedicated to his craft he did it
really
yeah look he he was eating a pack of
cigarettes every night
on stage and swallowed
a yeah and then but wait he also throws
him into his mouth like
oh my god so now he's chewing him
watch what is he chewing he's just
amazing but hold on
i get to where he's throwing them into
his mouth too oh boy
yes he throws him into his mouth one of
the time they're lit he chews them up
swallows them his mouth is lighting
look at the ladies what the [ __ ] am i
doing here
oh my god look at that stack in his
mouth
and then look the whole thing goes in by
the way he also throws him one at a time
does all that puts the paper in oh
jesus christ and swallows it all
that's it oh my god yep he
he's so so how did this kill him
every single night just 20. he shows a
night at a bar
doing cigarettes in your mouth on fire
eating them
swallowing them right but what killed
yeah yeah boy yeah but wait so
um so he spits them out eventually or he
just swallows him
i'm not gonna give away his genius right
in the video do they ever come out no no
they're gone they just yeah yeah
yeah see that's the thing it's like this
is a guy that died for his
art legitimately yeah wow
but so another the guy was telling you
about that's like my favorite card
the guy that taught that showed me the
navy seal but just an amazing just as a
library
he um he's like this genius that if he
came here which he never would because
he would never show anybody
anything but if he did and he showed you
a couple of moves
like the first move he showed me was
actually a card move called ascension
where he makes the card float right
through the deck and like the greatest
magician of all time the card magician
said it was one of the greatest tricks
ever done you won't be able to find it
anywhere because it's not a video
but he um he only does it to a couple of
magicians
so he performs for like you know a
handful of his friends
he shows a move and it's mind-blowing
and
luckily he showed me stuff when i was
young but
he'll never ever perform he's like does
a painter paint so he can show people or
does a painter paint to paint
but whenever you're on the phone with
him you just hear cards like he's like
and he's doing no and he's doing it he's
doing i'm telling you like 13 day long
13 hours a day he's doing card moves
alone
and i said but i was like bill what do
you do do you like do the trick to
yourself and be like ah
how did i do that you know what i mean
but he said he doesn't believe that it's
not to him it's not a performance
to him it's it's just about the
technical love and feel of
of that well that's that there's a
japanese phrase for that about doing
something
over and over and over and over the
exact same thing over and over again
until you achieve a level of perfection
that is almost physically unattainable
to
mere mortals you you bypass
what a person thinks the the body would
be capable of doing
yep yeah that that's that's it that's it
yeah that's what he's doing that is the
thing like if you can
you know james nestor is yeah of course
he wrote the book d
yes yeah deep is amazing uh i don't know
deep but
that's the book yeah breath is the one
that i read and i had him on the podcast
he's amazing he was talking about this
monk that uh
was literally meditating and
doing breathing exercises all day long
for 30 years
and could do these insane things with
his body like vary the temperature from
one hand to another change the blood
flow
to change it literally from one finger
to this for sure and that
yeah you're the only way you could get
to that place
is you have to be that guy who sits in a
cave and does breath work
all day long for 30 years and most
people just aren't willing to do that
but if you do do that
there are some levels that you can reach
that are just unattainable to a normal
person and even
if you would talk to but i agree with
the scientists and the doctors no but it
is attainable to normal
people because when somebody gets
paralyzed or something right i've seen
people that the doctors say you're done
you have no shot
and they spend all day of every single
waking moment trying to get like a
little mo
just like a tiny bit of movement in
their little toe and eventually if
they do what you're saying yes so it it
is that
yeah it is that it's but most people are
not
willing to get to that place most people
are not going to sit there shuffling
cars 13 hours a day like your friend
yeah but there's people that can do that
like when i was watching you move the
cards around
well it's interesting like you ever
watch a movie where a guy smoking a
cigarette you know that guy doesn't
really smoke
you can kind of tell by the way he's
holding the cigarette it feels good
that's good you're moving these cards
around like your
your edge detection like your
understanding of where the edge
it's very interesting to watch your
fingers move because they're so
they're so educated you know um because
of uh
all the commentary that i do with
martial arts and my years in martial
arts
it's i'm fascinated by how different
people move and they do the same thing
they it looks different when other
people do it there's certain people that
will throw a punch
and you just walk into you you go jesus
there's something about the
the fluidity of the motion that's
stunning even to this day
and that was just when i was watching
you move your fingers and watching you
move the cards like this [ __ ] i
shuffled a lot of cards
there's a weirdness to the the movement
of your hands
but i think it's what you're saying it's
like the punch thing it's like there's
yes yeah
yeah but it's uh it is but it's it's
the you you the mind forces the body
into moving over and over and over again
you know
you do it to this level of perfection
that you d for a person like me who
doesn't know anything about cards i
don't know anything about car tricks i
don't know how they work
i can't shuffle if you watch me shuffle
you'd [ __ ] laugh at me
but i watch your your hand movements i'm
like oh
this is amazing it's amazing but now
there's guys that i'm around
that i wouldn't even pull a deck of
cards out of my pocket if they're near
me because they're that guy that does it
13 hours yeah like yeah like
like the guy just that's what he's done
fascinating though but
yeah but there's also different aspects
of it but so like you know there's also
guys
i can't i'm not gonna go with the
details okay
but i met i feel like i shouldn't even
say this but it's fine
because it's fine so i met a kid once
who moved to las vegas when he was
this is a crazy story to tell damn
but it's a good story okay i won't go
into details
so he moved to las vegas when he was 12.
he moved there because he wanted to meet
a specific person who was considered
the best card sheet ever meaning the guy
this is a guy that the reason that vegas
has
those instead of like the dealer peeking
the
the down card they have to put it into a
machine and push a button
he's the guy that the movie casino was
built around with the computer in the
shoe like he was the
the best card she ever
but among magicians he's like a
phenomenon because he's working on moves
not to entertain
anybody he's working on moves so he
doesn't get his hands smashed up against
the wall
binions right so he's working on moosa
he's not going to get killed
survival yes yeah so right so
this kid at the age of 12 knows about
him
moves to las vegas and buys a crap
stable
he puts the craps table it's him and his
mom right it was my the
single mother and him they live in this
small apartment very close to
the man i was telling you about and this
kid throws dice
15 hours a day on this craps table by
the way their
little bed is like under the table you
know i mean it's a small space and it's
a real
crap stable like a nice one the only
thing he does is
repetitiously throw that and he can
helicopter spin the dice
so you can't see them doing this they
have such force going around this way
that when they hit the wall
one die won't break the number and he
can throw it exactly to this
part of the of the table missing this
from across the table so that one guy
locks and every time he can guarantee
that number
he did that every day for almost a
decade until he could throw dice better
than any other human being in the world
then he went and got a job at one of the
casinos that texts for
car cheats and worked in the craps
tables
it's all he did and as soon as he turned
21
he went out travels the world and wins
the exact amount of money that he should
when playing craps where you're not
detected but
but you can what is the exact amount i
mean i under
you know probably under a million yeah
probably a few million a year so if i'm
saying it's not like he's going in and
getting really it's it's very smart and
structured
yeah and that's going to different
places and he can throw dice like i've
never seen anybody throw dice
it's crazy i know that they take people
that are really good at cards like my
friend dana white has been
barred from casinos because he wins at
blackjack he's probably just counting
i don't know what he's doing yeah he's
counting but they've they've kicked him
out of casinos because he's won
a lot of money but he's also lost a lot
of money which is bizarre to me that you
can go to a place
and do really well and they're like
you're doing too well you got to get out
of here well they also it says mine
everything we have the
right to refuse anybody which is
important because do they do that with
dice is the question i forget that how
they would do that okay
do you want to hear a dice story but
this isn't me doing magic this is luck
okay okay so i don't believe you it is i
don't like the way you paused
but but i'm serious i know but i'm
saying that because i'm trying to be
convincing okay okay
so because i'm telling the truth but
anyway
i go to the palms you know the yeah okay
and um
they had a bet on the crabs table called
the fire bet and
it was like a a game where you have to
hit all the numbers open and close
without
but crapping out so
when i walk up to the table right away
the
the pit boss and everybody they make a
big deal like you can't touch the dice
and they're like i said you can call up
i can touch the dice because
you know they invite me so i can touch
the dice
and uh because i i wanted to throw right
i don't want to just gamble on a rant so
anyway i um
because even though i'm not cheating i
still feel like you know maybe i'll get
i have a little bit of an ability that's
giving you know what i mean
right not a cheating ability but maybe
i'm a little better than a random person
i don't know
right got it so the pit ball
they make a joke and then the woman
pitbull comes out she says well if you
take your shirt off we'll let you throw
the dice
joking right so anyway what i do is i
bet for
everybody at the in this i go to the low
stakes table always so the high stakes
able's that super bowl team right over
there and they're like ah
they're all crazy right like all excited
with these big bets
over here with this table we all have
little bats right that i say let's put a
fire bet down for everybody
so i put the fire bit down for every
single person at the table
including the dealers the i mean the
pitbull you know the
you know with the dicing and uh i'm
throwing the dice throwing the dice
this goes on for two and a half hours i
keep throwing the dice
i didn't hit us i didn't crap out i hit
sevens in between each number which you
can
craps work so you have to roll like a
five let's say and then i'm like oh no i
need to roll another
five which is statistically much more
difficult than a seven because seven is
the most
common number to come up so if you roll
a five you're like uh oh that's hard
because you can only get a two three or
a three two
on both dice or a one four or 4 1. so
you have a
4 out of 36 so it's a 1 and 9. so you're
probably going to crap out before you
get the number that's why the game is
to their favor so i'm throwing the dice
and it's two and a half hours later and
they stop everything and they're like
your fire bet just hit
and the table goes what does that mean
they go well you all just won
like 10 grand each and they'll go ah
like everybody's go they gave me the
taser everybody's going nuts and we hit
the fire bet which they've now removed
from the palms by the way but it was
it was a pretty unheard of like the odds
of hitting that bet is
pretty rare but it's just luck
nobody should hit that bet i mean
statistically it's unlikely and i wasn't
cheating
so yeah so
do they but the the question is i'm
lucky
for some reason i'm light i'm lucky with
dice right but i'm not i
but i can tell you i would be if i was
great with dice i'd tell you i was good
by the way i actually have a thigh on me
i didn't even hear this story for this
reason but i do have a die on me
have you practiced with dice um no yes
but i'm terrible at it so or do i do
i do have a diet but it does make sense
that if
you look at what that is that that's a
physical thing
and then if you develop a touch you
develop a feel
you do something over and over and over
well this is different but here look
take the die
okay and and uh can you like
uh put it between your hand or whatever
like uh and can you mix it like that
and then squeeze it when you're done or
no keep it hidden but put it on the
table but make sure you can't see it and
i can't see it
you agree like no one could see that
right are you sure 100
do you want to do it again try it again
just know because it could be weighted
so just
or you're done you're good yeah you're
good yeah okay uh
say a number between one and six like
pick a number up to six
okay that five is what i said on the
craps table right but
but i already know that it's a four
and the five is here basically
how do you know that that's
uncomfortable
can you do that again probably not
so you know what we'll do stop but stop
whatever you want yeah because it could
be like a way to die by the way that's
how people cheat
with dices they also take the dye and
they flip it
and they want it to be you know so it's
like you throw the numbers so you said
you wanted a five right yeah
go ahead yeah it's five get that voodoo
away from me man
the [ __ ] is that
that's so weird that must be a rush for
you though just to blow people's minds
like that all the time
but see so it's not you don't i don't
think of it so what happens is the
digital fixation part of like the love
of just like learning something new and
exciting that's
that's like really the the stimulus is
like that
that fixation almost it's like the
meditative thing that you're talking
about but
but as a magician that is performing and
trying to make tv shows it's really
difficult because you have to like keep
coming up with new things which is
that's hard to do how did you first
get on television how did you convince
someone to let you try this on
television well
so back in those days the only magic
that you could see and like i said it
was pre you couldn't go
watch it or get it or any so there's no
way to see magic and if you were me
with a single mother in brooklyn or
whatever how you gonna go
there's no magic i never went to a magic
show
so what happened was all those world's
greatest tv specials were playing and
they were called world's greatest men
and i would watch them and they were
like the opposite of that they were like
not they were like hard to watch you
know it was like glossy big
like dynamic and illusionist is so far
away from the whole thing so
i'm like there's nothing magical about
all this and then um
so okay i i i think about it and i'm
like
i go through up so but i'm doing magic
everywhere all the time so
one of the ways i'm making money is i'm
going into those fancy restaurants in
new york city like those
upper park avenue and i do magic to the
you know to the manager
to this and i'm like if uh
can i do magic to the table and it's
like what i did to you there like do the
magic like oh that's great
i was like could i do magic to the
people eating and i won't ask him for
anything
i bought like a nice suit at century 21
like a hundred dollar jacket was
tattooed but
anyways i go up to these tables and
that's
a hard situation because it's very
difficult to approach people that do not
want you near them
and try to figure out how to win with
magic it's a com and it's like
even on the street wherever you do it
it's like a complicated scenario
once the camera comes up it changes it
because now they're like oh he has a
camera it's fine right
but you'd have to walk up to a table of
a people a bunch like us we're sitting
there
and some like you know sketchy magician
kid
comes up to us like hey can i show you a
card trick and you and i
are gonna be like nice to him probably
but not really whatever out
right so what i had to learn quickly was
like little things that are so important
like distance like how close should you
be to the table or how
far and then you start to really
understand the psychology of the magic
is way more important than the tricks
right so if you're too
close you're like over you're they don't
want you near them so you're right
you get you're like they're like no
thank you if you're too far away it's
easy for them to say no thank you right
so there's like a balancing point just
on where you stand
and then who you do the first trick to
and then what the first trick is and
so by doing all this i started to really
figure out how to get reactions from
anybody really fast so i could walk up
to anybody
anywhere and just do magic like one time
i was in um
central booking because i jumped the
subway thing they were sweeping
everybody up
and there was four guys sitting in the
middle playing spades
the only other like kid that looked like
me that was in there got the [ __ ] kicked
out of him right
and i'm like i'm gonna get my ass kicked
right because i was with a button-up
shirt like you know
anyway so the guys are sitting in the
middle
uh that were playing spades i grabbed it
i go let me show you guys something i
take the come on
i grab the deck of cards and i start
doing magic to the four
toughest looking guys in the cell right
within two minutes
they're erupting and once they're
erupting the whole everybody because
central books are moved here everybody's
standing around going nuts and then all
of a sudden
the guards are there and now everybody's
watching together and i'm like
this is what the magic show needs to be
like whether you're like here or this
whether you're this that whether you're
young old witch poor black white
whatever everybody wants to see it
no no everybody's got a good side like
there's
i want to show the that people are all
the same you know like
sure there's some that are horrific and
do horrible but at the core of
everybody there's like an innocent kid
somewhere maybe he got really
far lost and magic just pulls that out
of people
you know and that's why and the people
say oh well how could you do magic
i do magic to anybody because whether
it's like visiting
underage kids in prison that like you
don't know what happened to them
and you see them come walking up with
their eyes down they don't want to look
at you because they don't like anybody
there that's authority right that's what
ruined their lives
and then as soon as you do these tricks
suddenly they're like
little happy sweet kids ah
you get the you get that and that's what
and that's what magic did originally to
my mom like i would do it to her
and she'd be like reacting and even if
she had a terrible day you know she was
working three jobs it was like
this made her happy wow
that's that's a cool origin story that
and it makes sense that that feeling
that you get
like when you show so many like in you
like the card trick you did in the other
room and everybody's like oh
that that oh the oh that you get out of
people that that rush
that's that that is because at that
moment no one's thinking of anything
else
at that moment they're like what the
[ __ ] how did you
what oh and by the way i've walked
many times when people were fighting
about to erupt into big fights i walked
into the middle of those fights
started doing magic and those fights no
i know but and then the fights were done
and everybody's like what do you want to
hear the funniest non-magical magic
story
sure okay so after the tv show comes out
stuff like that i get more known by the
way it's a world's greasy but then i was
like okay let me do the opposite of that
so i called it street magic because i
was trying to come up with the
lowest name like i was trying to come up
with center expectations as low as
possible
right because the world's greatest like
so i come i'm doing like card tricks
right but anyway so
i'm like driving with my friend at his
uh one of those those smart cars in new
york and it's like the coldest day in
new york it's like
freezing like a february like 12 degrees
out type situation
and um we're stuck at a red light
and there's a car with these four people
outside of it
and there you could see they're like
struggling like they couldn't get the
door open so they realized they
and they didn't they lost their keys
they couldn't figure it out they
couldn't get into their car
right but i know that that's not what's
going on like
it's freezing so i understand the
situation so i go doug
stop one second and i walk up next to
these
this group walk up to the car pull the
door open
but i like it made it look like i'm just
pulling but i was giving it for
the door opens up and it looks like i
did nothing it did i get back at the
card leave and i hear they go down steve
they got it was like the best trick i
ever did but it was just opening up a
door in a frozen night because i knew
that it was just frozen
but that's the same as what magic is
it's like it's like and when
yeah so the and the whole so that
there's a book called magic and
showmanship which is
all about like what makes magic
effective and it's called like the ham
sandwich
he says if you just said reach in your
pocket right now there's a ham sandwich
that's a good trick but if you were like
man i'm hungry i would love a hand
sandwich
and i'd already put it there and i'm
like reaching your pocket and then
there's
that's real magic so it's just context
that's where it's so baffling because
then people walk away how the [ __ ] did
he know i was going to say a ham
sandwich
like the folded car that you somehow
another shoved into jeff's wrist into
his
below his watch we're all like okay what
i mean i know there's something to it i
don't know what you're doing but
that oh the result the o is uh pretty
pretty phenomenal but in that moment no
one's thinking of anything else
uh yeah but it's sure no but there's
also a lot of people that are trying to
figure it out they're skeptical
but they're still going ah they're not
even if they're trying to figure it out
they're not thinking of anything other
than that trick
that moment something yeah they might be
trying to figure it out but they're
still they're not thinking about
oh i gotta feed the dog you know they're
they're thinking about that
they're like good friends of mine
they're doing magic they're like okay
yeah we can all get uh too accustomed to
things yeah
so you you first get on television you
first
do these things and then your magic
evolves
and your magic goes from being just
magic to some of the
more insane things you've done like
standing in a block of ice for how long
did you do it for seven days like 63
hours
i'm always late so i showed up late so i
missed like what i
the length of time i was supposed to do
so that's all but i'm always late
i made it here on time though didn't i
you were early yeah yeah
perfect but i rode the motorcycle here
and was flying because
i had to make i wanted to be on time so
i flew you were on time yeah
um the the ice thing why what made you
decide to stand in a block of ice okay
60 plus hours well so i'll tell you that
so you were saying how do you go from
the magic tricks like to these extreme
physical endurance and
so studying houdini and all that stuff
and then there's a poster of houdini
that i loved where he was it was
he was buried alive but he never did the
stunt he died before he got to do but he
was gonna get buried alive underground
in a coffin
so i i stare at i love that poster since
i was a kid it's like in the magic books
you see that poster
yeah in any way so bill again the guy i
told you about bill kalush
comes up to me and he's like what about
this and he shows me an image of a
indian fakira that was buried alive for
a month he's like what if you pretend to
be buried alive in central park we'll
sneak you out and you'll come back a
month later
and i was like i always wanted to do
like houdini-like things
but i never wanted to copy but that one
he never did so i was kind of like well
that's interesting
but what if instead of doing it the way
he did it what if i did it
and everybody could see that i was
buried alive so what if i was really
just buried alive like it can't be that
hard
he's like yeah you can't do that and i
was staying at his place so we got a
coffin
from queens where actually houdini was
buried i bought a coffin we brought it
back to his house
and then i would just practice sleeping
in the coffin then suddenly yeah
i know but then suddenly i realize you
don't eat food and then if you have a
little thing to go to the bathroom i did
four days like nothing so i'm like okay
i can do a week
and that was it and then then i pushed
the idea of doing the bird alive and
and convinced people to let me do it
publicly and what's funny is
like firemen and stuff like would come
to the stunt in the middle of the night
and they would shine like holograms at
me and their lights and stuff
and they oh that's the ice but and then
they would assume that i wasn't
actually in there okay so here so back
to this one
well well let's go but but let's let's
not jump around
the so the buried alive thing yeah where
did you do it physically where
um that was in new york city on the west
side uh
trump had like this uh bunch of
properties that he was developing
and i was like uh i want to be buried
alive on one of your properties
is that possible he's like sure he just
sent me his driver and i went around and
that's where i did my first thought and
it was how could they see you though and
then jimmy
who i do who like oh there you go yeah
so it was see-through but right
and then we put six tons of water on top
of it so that's basically it
and then so i was there and how are you
getting that
there was hal see those two big holes so
the oxygen was being see the holes above
my head
right there so the air was being blown
in and out but it's pretty
straightforward like
that one's not to me not that impressive
like if i said to you you just laid
there for a week
yeah that you know what the harder the
hard part i mean sure you
body and you lose right now but the hard
part of it is um
and you wouldn't you would never
anticipate this being the hard part
but if you're not used to like peeing
while standing in front of lots of
people
staring at you it's actually really hard
so so i'd be buried alive and i had the
trucker's tube on and all that stuff
which is like a con with a catheter or
whatever
and um and people are there the whole
time like it suddenly became like an
event and so there was never
like and i was they were like oh we'll
cover it so no one can see i'm like no
then people are going to think i'm
sneaking in and out so i had to learn
so i would close my eyes like when you
were a kid sleeping and you would have
those dreams i'd have bachelors
and it would take me hours and i'd
finally be able to pee
right but that and by the way i didn't
eat for a few weeks before so i
had no foods that was the other wasn't
an issue but um what happened by midway
through the stunt people i'd be waving
and smiling
and like and it was like nothing you
know but these are things that you don't
consider when you're
practicing in your coffin in your house
so you you didn't eat for how long two
weeks before
yeah yeah but i i was always into
fasting i read sid artha as a kid
and i had done like uh a week with just
water and you know knew all that knew
the body is really good with that
so you were comfortable with the fact
that you were able to fast and
that that wouldn't be an issue yeah and
you were comfortable with the fact that
you were getting air and where are you
drinking water from how you getting
water oh i had like a little bit of
water in there that i could suck to a
thing
like that and that was fine it was like
it was enough
how much water do you think you drank
over the week that you were in there
uh i i don't know they always say it was
like just a little bit but it was a good
amount it was like uh
i don't know probably probably
three liters a day or something oh okay
yeah that's real yeah they say he did
tablespoons of it but no it was
it was it was like a normal amount so
by the way i did 44 days with nothing
but water and i did nothing but
pure h2o so it's not even like it had
minerals in it
and body was full recovery and my
starvation expert who's like one of the
top guys in the world
in london my doctor at the end thought
that i was cheating
so they put me on and i distilled water
it was a company called h2o and they're
things it's just
pure yeah just exactly distilled right
so
right which which is irrelevant by the
way but so
i had nothing but pure h2o for 44 days
lost 60 pounds bmi bone mass index
dropped
33 percent yeah people that's what i was
getting yeah no no it was bad no it
wasn't
yeah it wasn't good but doctor thought i
was cheating because he's a magician by
the way
my friends that were with me that are
you know magicians and the guy building
they're like you need to take these
vitamins and they hand me a handful
of sugary vitamins and i'm like no
it's just because i if i'm gonna do it i
want to like actually do it right right
and um if i would have taken those
vitamins i feel like my metabolism
wouldn't have gone into starvation
and i might have had irreversible damage
from it
so the fact that i actually did it i
went into starvation mode and the body
protects itself but what i was saying is
the starvation expert that now i have a
paper published
in the new england journal medicine with
him which i'm pretty proud about
but um he he didn't believe me so he put
me on an iv and right away the phosphate
levels reacted and i almost went into
shock
so i almost actually did die when they
refit fed me so his paper is called the
refeeding syndrome
they say like after world war ii when
they rescued the from the
from the camps the jews and everybody
was starving the camps
and they a lot of soldiers gave them
like candy bars and stuff and all of a
sudden their systems
went into shock and they died from not
being refed the right way
so what is the correct way to re-feed
someone if they haven't eaten you have
to slowly bring them back so that you
don't have what happened to me which is
phosphate levels
go all crazy so very small amounts of
food yeah but then two days later i
somebody sent me a trunk from harrods
full of food
in london like a friend and uh
and i was giving it to all the nurses
and doctors because i knew i shouldn't
eat it and i was trying to do it right
then like in the middle of the night
i woke up and had like a bag of potato
chips right
and then um a bagel a creature and i was
wrecked it was like the most
i also didn't go to the bathroom for a
month and a half
what think about that
so how long does it take you to recover
from one of these things
that one i feel like i never fully
recovered from but
i don't know i wouldn't recommend
anybody does that like goes like super
super long with no food but
but by the way so there's no you don't
think you ever recover yeah
my body always goes like this now it's
always confused when i like train i go
up
down really quick really easy and it was
since that sorry because you thought
your body freaked out because it wasn't
when you started
yeah i feel like that yeah you know but
there's no way to prove that but
um that's a common thing though with
people who cut weight for fights
really yeah they get to a certain point
they have kidney failure
and yeah yeah and then that's why right
exactly that's what happened to me and i
keep having problems with my kidneys
yes yeah yeah and i have a spot on my
kidney right now
mm-hmm yeah yeah
yeah that's uh that's a real common one
with guys uh daniel cormier actually had
to drop out of the olympics because of
that
i didn't know that his kidneys failed
yeah kidney failure is a big one with uh
fighters kidney stones too for a lot of
guys wait
so you're that was probably in your
opinion the one that damaged you the
most
or left the most residual so the most
difficult one was the ice
by far the the ice was a monster and the
reason why
was because and now there's also
something great about it so
it was a warm november so the air coming
through was like
you know it happened to be a 68 degree
three-day spread which led to the ice
keep
dripping the cold on me and it's
radiating this way but i'm also standing
up in one spot completely still and you
can't sleep because if you fall asleep
when you're present to ice you get
frostbite you have to cut your skin off
right
so i'm staying completely awake the
entire time
and it's a difficult situation on hour
55
exactly if i look back at all of it my
friends knew
my eyes just go out and i'm now
hallucinating
like you could never ever there no
hallucinogenic drug will
ever give you those kind of
hallucinations like what was it
first of all it's amazing but it's also
when it goes into that nightmare part
it's scary
but there's also that amazing part of it
and if you have people
after that stunt now whenever i
hallucinate on stunts i have
friends there that i say i'm gonna start
hallucinating just talk me through it
but so here's when i started realizing
that i was hallucinating because you
don't know when you are right
um and by the way the one stunt i never
did was sleep deprivation
if you remind me i'll explain that whole
thing but i'll forget but so
um so what happens is when i start
realizing it is i need to know
uh like what time it is because i'm done
at 10 p.m because it was live on abc so
i'm like
i need to know how much longer i got to
go through this right because it's
getting tough
so and it's there the by the way and my
doorman would come in like
news or whatever fox news said david
blaine
um is not really the i they did a
special on it a
an hour-long special on fox saying that
i was never in the ice and i had a
double
of me that was in the ice i'm switching
up and down with the
eating burgers and readings
stations oh yeah yeah so they did but
they did a one-hour special that i was
never in there so my dorm
how do they get away with doing that i
don't know i don't care but listen so my
doormat my doorman who comes to
this is the funny part though so my
doorman that comes to see me
he he's um he knows me so well he's
buried alive and he's so nice right
so he comes to visit me in new york and
uh he he walks up to the ice
and he sees me and he's looking at me
all weird i wasn't hallucinating it
looked at me all weird then he leaves
and then when i go back i was like
what's up he's like
that are you sure that that was you and
ice
could that have been you i was like what
do you mean eddie he's like
okay well it's you know so he we go on
that special heirs now he's convinced
that it wasn't me and i
especially is why you're still no no
that's after but he already
thinks because he doesn't believe it my
friends my best friends when i was
buried alive
they didn't think i was really doing it
they thought it was a trick
right so so he he asked me he's like
there's
was that really you because they said
that you were a double of yourself and
you were
switching and i was like eddie but you
looked at me
like how could if i have a twin brother
like where is that identical twin
brother
and why why would i switch up so anyway
but so back to the um
back to the when i get to 55 hours so
i'm looking
around and i need the time so i go like
this like
what time is it and the guy goes
402 yeah so he shows me 402.
so i'm like okay that means we have like
another six hours or whatever it is
right
and by the way my time estimations are
so i'm like okay
wait it might have been too way
way way and i wait and i'm indoor it's
hard
i'm like things are moving everything's
weird spiders are walking up people are
like sitting in the ice
i'm waiting waiting voices are talking
to me that i'm talking back to
right but i'm waiting i'm waiting and i
wait
for like a few hours before i ask
anybody the time again
and i see somebody and i'm like
and the guy and the guy goes
four oh three oh no
and that's when it all crashed out it
was like when that went up
that connection and then the
hallucinations were just rampant and my
eyes were all crazy when the
drill was when the chainsaw was coming
through i tried to grab it
yeah so yeah see look at that oh you're
gone
but okay but sudden but now that i've
learned that
sleep deprivation is one of the
most amazing ways if it's controlled
to go to another place it's like that
but i want to get to that before we get
to that like
while you're in there what are you doing
to occupy your mind like
how are did you have were you using
meditation were you just
thinking were you just winging it like
so okay so
for some of them what i do a big first
of all yeah a lot of things you get to
you have free time to think like there's
no
phones no distractions so aside from the
physic
but but the one thing that i use with
everything is kind of like a breakdown
of numbers i'm like okay
this much i have to get to this point
then when i get to this point even when
i run on a treadmill i'm like okay i
have to get to this point which means
let me get to the halfway point and i'll
consider that
when i'm holding my breath i do the same
thing like okay i need to get to 15
minutes so let me get to seven and i'll
start at seven then at seven i'm like
okay i'm at seven left i have to get to
another three and a half then three and
a half
and then what i always do is whenever
i'm training i always go past it so it's
the same thing so like when i'm running
a treadmill
i'm like if i have to do let's say like
you know 3.1 whatever it is
i set that as my target but then i
always go like another
half a mile past it because i won't you
can't quit before because then you'll be
in the mindset that okay i can stop
before so like anything that i do i use
numbers to get there i get halfway and
then i push the goal further
every single time no matter what
which is so it's a mathematical system
ironically so you're
you're you don't necessarily have any
sort of meditative techniques you're
just concentrating on the numbers
meditation for breath holding all the
time right every time i do a breath
now the ice was kind of like there was
like a breathing thing and i didn't
really know much about it back then but
i was like more like fighting it like
what is it like on your ankles or your
knees and your back everything swells up
like edema really bad and all that stuff
and the pain is excruciating and
unbearable but yeah it's
i mean you're waiting and you didn't
have any residual
effects of that just my ankles and legs
were really small just for a few days
or so longer than that but yeah yeah
now has anybody ever tried to break that
uh
i don't know i hope not not because i
want i don't care about how i just don't
want anybody hurt themselves
but i would imagine like someone does
something so high profile like you did
that
that people be like i'm gonna try that i
mean i think it's too weird so people
aren't really like oh i want to do that
but there's billions of people i would
imagine that someone would step in and
try to
emulate that obviously it was saying i
pray not and that's why i pray my
daughter never becomes a magician even
though she's so amazing at it because if
she started doing
these things i like if she's gonna bump
her knee up like i have a heart attack
you know
well that's the problem with being a
parent right yeah
the things that make you amazing are
your ability to overcome adversity and
then you shelter your children from
adversity
you know it's all my favorite people are
all
they all came from a very tumultuous
childhood
they all came from like turmoil and no
one wants that for their child you want
to protect your children yeah
weird it's very weird so what other ones
have you done
where like while you were doing it
you were thinking what the [ __ ] have i
done
because you're committed there was one
that don't
don't pull this one up don't pull this
one
it was called the dive of death and i
started to get cocky i'd done like the
thing in london i'd done like the water
tank i'd done
so i started to get too cocky right i
didn't have time and abc won the show
really quick
i was like okay i'm going to go upside
down for 60 hours three days
whatever right i was gonna be upside
down and then um
and then i some guy was in a parachute
upside down on a tree in italy and he
was in the hospital because he was three
days upside down in the tree
and i was trying to speak to him but he
was like not
he didn't want to talk at all and then
they were like it's his situation's
really bad so it kind of like set the
tone before i did the thing the
situation's really bad like that from
being upside down for that long
what happened to him i i think he's the
blood i think it
i think it does i i don't know because
he didn't i didn't get to
ask they wouldn't tell me but he
wouldn't also engage in a
it was bad that i know it was like in
the news it was bad
um i don't know what the permanent
repercussion
but so when i did this thing upside down
in new york i didn't
practice it i thought i could just wing
it my stunt guy who
taught me to jump off the pole he's like
you can never ever
just go wing something and not dial it
in and rehearse and figure it out you
can't just go do it
it's a you'll you can't hope for luck
and that was the first one ever
and last one that i was like okay let me
just hope that i can do this
as soon as i went upside down remember i
said you could never prepare for certain
things
yeah i had that catheter hooked up and
the first time i peed it just went
upside down all over me so this way and
i was like i'm done
so the whole stunt went down over there
that was like
that was a great learning lesson because
i learned you never just dial it though
did you make it through that one yes but
it was terrible it was
a garbage stunt yes but you were asking
me like what things
so that was one that was like oh yeah
you're but all the others
they were amazing the team that working
with the best people
all of it and this one is the most
amazing like i have a team
that's the one you're doing right now i
have the most
amazing i've never been able to have a
team like this
ever balloon one yes okay explain this
okay so i went to youtube with crazy
idea
who by the way this is youtube and
they've been a blessing
beyond beyond so i'm like okay here's
what i want to do like i want to
grab a bunch of balloons and go floating
up into the sky and disappear like okay
great
okay sure right but so now i need it to
ascend
this is all hypothetical i'm not like a
skydiver like that has a thousand or ten
thousand or twenty thousand jumps
i'm not a balloon pilot i have no
experience in any of this stuff i just
know that i want to do this and i've
wanted to do it forever but i
i had drawings of it made 15 years ago
but now you have to get for real so
there is a guy that flies balloons and
there's a guy like
lawn chair larry that went up on
balloons with like a lawn chair and a
bunch of beer that was his ballast and
he like popped balloons with a gun
so there are examples so it's not like a
complete hypothetical this one has like
okay so what if i could take
the balloons that idea and just have the
innocent image of a kid like we all
dream of just holding the balloons and
drifting
up and into the sky here i'll show you a
picture
what's that what's that one from their
website
from whose website is that jamie balloon
company
right so that's that's my balloon
is that you up there yeah we yeah we did
um
we did short flights not big in public
we kept it small
can i show these to jamie
no i don't know yeah
to him and i can show you sean can you
show it i feel like
i'm not sure all right then don't wait
that's my balloons yeah
oh well that's on but that yeah that's
the end of it i'm doing it yeah it's
just
right so this is but i i i i think maybe
maybe not
because but anyway so so okay so it
starts with just the idea of that
but now i have to go get a hot air
balloon pilot license
so i go meet with the best hot air
balloon pilot
instructor and also flyer but isn't that
the different situation than a hot air
balloon because you don't have the
ability to control
you have to first get your hot air
balloon pilot license so you have to
learn how to fly and land the bloom
which is amazing
right it's like so app and then you have
to take that written test and i don't
have time because i'm trying to do so
much
so i had to cram study the whole written
test in eight hours
with a guy helping me i studied the
whole thing went to the airport took the
test got that
then you need to go get your gas
restriction lifted which means because
and very few people even ever bothered
to do this because who's flying hydrogen
or helium nowadays
so i went and met this guy bert pidelt
who's the best gas balloonist in the
world he's the one that built around the
world in 80 days he's built every
balloon that's done the longest fights
and you fly
now a hot air balloon you're like
right you have to control it and it's
helium and hydrogen
you're just part of the wind you're
literally just
floating away and it'll keep going up to
84
000 feet until they pop there like you
are just floating
like i can't explain that
feeling of floating anyway so i had to
go learn how to fly and land hydrogen
balloons and
use hydrogen because helium is more
expensive and stuff like that
now we have to go test the whole rig
so now and and at the same time i have
to also try to get as close to 500 jumps
out of an airplane because i need to be
really comfortable in the air
if i have to jump out and land i need to
land safely
right and when you're up at 25 plus
thousand feet you don't know where you
are
right so yeah so now and
by the way the video did you see the
video i made for you you didn't see it
no you made a video for me yeah because
when you did the thing with post
and and you in post was like he's not
real and you were defending me i was
like
um hold on i made a video i sent it to
matt i texted him i didn't get a video
he didn't show you
the video no hold on i made you this
video so this is me yelling from the
plane and by the way
this is after the wingsuit guys jump out
of the airplane so remember i'm also
crushing lots of jumps really fast this
one i ran into a fence and almost killed
myself and
the luke who's the best in the world
that has 25 000 more
jumps jumped from 25 000 feet without a
parachute and landed in a net
i saw that yeah so he's the guy coaching
me so he's the one
filming this and he landed at the state
troopers patrol thing because we were so
far
lost and i ended up trying to make it
back
almost hitting the trees really really
close and then crashing into a fence my
legs were all
bloodied up rip through the thing
flipped over landed i was fine that was
recent i was like
and the reason why is because i was
making you this video a complete truth
but i'm gonna explain it to you so to
make the video i had to wait till the
wing suits were out of the plane because
they're last right
but that means and by the way the
conditions you'll see what they were
like in a second
so the plane's moving really really far
away right because it's
still going that means the drop zone is
way over there
and i made the video and it was longer
than i said it was going to be and then
when we
jump we're like lost in the clouds and i
see the only hole
so i fly through the hole and now
because i flew through that hole
we're so far away from everything and i
should have followed luke and went to
the state patrol thing but i was like no
i'm going to make it just back
and but so here's the video i gave you
though
can we play it for other people yeah
okay why don't you air drop it to jamie
oh yeah
okay hold on so let me uh
isn't that funny though it's pretty wild
but you don't bumped out that i didn't
get this before oh
well yeah so i was going to like
post it or something i asked him if i
should and he's like well wait because
maybe he'll just do the show
so i think that's why he didn't maybe or
something
like i don't why i don't know hold on
maybe it got lost in the email or
something it might have gotten to one of
those
that the email dumps get pretty big
sometimes
the point where i can't keep up is it
young james
young jamie young james
okay so that's that one but then i'm
gonna show you the rest of the shop but
you might have to scroll through it to
get to it but
um i'll show you but by the way it's the
most amazing
so i'll show you the rest of that shot
and then you'll see where he landed and
where i landed so
i'm going to send you first the pretty
version of it you guys can like
cut through or whatever sure okay yeah
so i'm gonna edit i'm gonna just send
you like the full
and then go look through so
here's another one
when is this one supposed to be in two
weeks in two weeks
yeah and do you have to take into
consideration the wind
the like what with the current oh yeah
temperature
and that's why we can't like confirm a
location because winds determine
everything
so even though now i'm at like you know
almost
400 jumps the winds still decide where
you go
oh here so all right here we go
did you get that other one i i've only
got one okay i'm just gonna make sure
this is what you want me to play
all right well that's the first one so
we i can do this airdrop come back
sure okay okay check this
a little bit out it watch my last
youtube video
the show i hope to come show you in
person
because that might actually save my life
oh jesus christ okay but so you see the
clouds
now hold on this one's going to come so
you're hanging on to a plane how high
are you there
no that was just i don't know like 13
000. oh nothing
no but i went to speak no but i went to
yeah yeah but still you're still 13 000
feet off the air
hanging onto a plane and you jump off
maybe it's another one maybe it's this
one
it's hilarious that you're like oh it's
only 13 000 feet
hanging onto the wing of a plane and
then i let go on video
i know but you need to see i can i can't
play it here though right and show you
like this we have to air drop it because
it's going to air drop is better because
it's going
well i just want to send this one that
shows like how spectacular but i could
just say that
which explains what's going on so hold
on no which one because there's three
young james
uh the macbook pro jamie but there's
three
mvp doesn't matter it's click one and it
should work
now when you decide to do something like
this do you get an inspiration
and then you consult people to see if
it's feasible
like well so that's where i was lucky so
what i was saying is i come up with the
idea
and then i find a guy his name is
jonathan trapp he's the one that tried
to cross the atlantic with healing for
balloons
and but i mean he has it's like a full
system he has a basket so it's like a
real
balloon like a hot air balloon system
with so nobody's
ever done it where they just float where
their bodies are
the basket you know what i mean so he
had the whole system and then he came
and tested out and i was like could i go
try it like this and he's like no we're
not
ready you'll kill yourself or whatever
you're hanging on to the rope
yeah but i'm gonna make sure that i'm
not gonna have a parachute on and i'm
gonna
i'll i'll have a system so i'm
completely secure so i'm not gonna fall
off
but i'm not gonna wear the parachute
because i don't want to be
i want it to look like a kid just
holding on to balloons so like that
visual is the important part
so the parachutes up in the balloons but
once i get above
like uh a thousand feet or so i'm gonna
put the parachute on
so you're going to put the parachute on
while you're up there yeah and then i
want to see if how
high i can go you see
how do you think you can go well
so the highest thing on earth is mount
everest
right so that's kind of my
goal but i have to be careful because if
you
if you're if you don't come back down
you're dead so if you can't get down
from there that's
that zone is like the death zone so from
like 25
000 to 30 000 is very very dangerous you
can black out like this so
i'm gonna do a couple more hypoxic tests
and see if i'm right
i'll have emergency stuff up there like
oxygen if i need it
but i don't want to floating around with
you up there in the balloons yeah we
have like the
the way it's not dude your loved ones
panic when you start
plotting things like this my daughter
asks questions how old is she
nine and she asks great questions and um
the the plate the
tail number the plate is for me and her
so it's n for number but
nine for her age 47 for my age and then
db for me and her were both desa and
david blaine
but um which is the balloon that has
i made this has to be a registered
aircraft so we had to get it registered
we had to fly it up we had to prove that
it's completely safe we had to land it
with nobody on it so the body
one time that i went wasn't me it was
sand that weighed exactly what i weighed
we had to remote dump the sand we had to
use squibs to remote pop the balloons
fly it over and this is it twenty two
thousand feet
what is what is control possibly but is
it radio yeah yeah yeah exactly okay and
i i
have the whole team helping me that did
like alan used this when he jumped and
felix baumgartner when he jumped from
the edge of space so we have
don day the best meteorologist do they
have to weigh you
before you get on yeah it's precision
and then so we had to fly it all the way
up to 22 000 feet as proof that this
aircraft is actually
completely doable and then remote it
exactly where donde predicted we were
going to land it and we've done that
multiple times
we've flown it we've deployed the the
imitation
massive amount of time involved in
constructing one of these things and
orchestrating it
time and team and team is everything
so it'd be like you when you have like
the best trainers if you had like
your five best in the world like
tweaking you before fights like that
so when when you plan on doing something
like this did you bring this up
to to these folks these are the first
people the people you're doing it with
these are the people you brought it up
to the first time yeah nobody said get
the [ __ ] out of here with this nope
went straight to youtube and i was like
i have this he went through these guys
and
did they hesitate at all no they're
they're amazing
that that's crazy right it is all so
crazy
because it is just a hypothetical idea
that's insane that's
true and they did let me like but there
were stages i had to prove each step so
i had to prove that number one
the balloon is doable number two i'm not
gonna hopefully kill myself number three
i can actually get the
oh and then for the skydives by the way
because i had to get 500 jumps really
quick and this is all during the last
year right um so insurance wouldn't
cover that i mean they would cover but
it's not affordable so i had to do five
almost 500 400 jumps or so with no
insurance and so that's a whole separate
thing that's not related so i had to go
do them for my own
as fun and do everything through my own
you see so it's crazy it's all nuts
because
because you think of skydiving think
like oh you have the best coach it's
fine but there's still
like when you're trying to do 15 jumps a
day it's like
you can do what i did which is try to
avoid hitting an airplane in a hangar
and turn too low
and come whacking down when did you come
up with this idea
uh i mean i think it was like inspired
when i was a kid i think like the idea
of like the little boy drifting around
balloons
i think it was like but i never really
thought of it as a reality but then
15 years ago or so i had drawings made
of it so i started having
i'll show you the drawings i can't open
it on there or whatever so when did you
put it into motion
um like it was never even possible until
youtube said okay we'll back this
because the idea is like all of my other
stunts there's like
the budget's pretty very you know
not you couldn't afford to do something
like this this is to build test a flight
build an actual aircraft fly it land it
get all the jumps learn how to do
everything get all the skill set having
so this is but that's the first drawing
oh wow yeah so you drew this when you
were
i didn't draw it oh someone else did
yeah mark stutzman who's an amazing
artist that did my poster for this thing
which i'll show you so
can i send this to jamie yeah it's not
working but you can try
airdrop's not working uh i noticed
something weird was happening when he's
trying to do it
i can but maybe the picture will go
if not i can restart the phone and maybe
it'll work
was it showing up for you jamie no right
let me restart the phone there's a lot
of uh
okay now it says it's waiting
there's like so many macbook pros you
got it yeah there's three oh when
yeah someone went through okay then i'll
also send oh but wait so should i also
show you the poster that i had made
okay um
so you you come to youtube powerful
youtube
they come up with the side i mean they
agree with
that's the original but this is the
latest one so
did you send that one to him too yeah
i'll send it to you jamie
it's coming through right now supposedly
i think it's like i have to accept them
for some reason
it doesn't just go is it showing up for
you
no i think i should restart the phone
because those videos too i want to send
there goes okay how did you get it to go
though which one did you press
i don't know there's so many of them
doesn't make any sense
your phone is being monitored by the
government they're cloning
hold on i want to try to send this video
so i could explain making your video if
that's possible
but then when you oh now it's preparing
it so now okay
beautiful now it's going through you
have it coming
right now because it says it's
converting so it might be coming
we're waiting for an accept on this so
okay
as soon as i get that so you bring this
to youtube
and how long ago was it uh
like a year and a half ago or something
like that they say yeah
let's do it we're [ __ ] crazy yeah
and also it's probably going to have 100
million people watch it so it seems like
i don't know i don't know about that oh
i do yeah i don't know i'm gonna float
around in a
[Laughter]
but this one by far is my favorite that
i've ever done it's the most
visual the most colorful it's the first
one that i've ever done
where my friends are like i want to do
that right they're not like
why do you do that you're holding on but
you know all the other since i do people
are like
like that's it's great that you're doing
it but that's crazy or why are you doing
it
this one they're like i want to ride the
balloons
because it's such a childhood yeah
they're they're yeah like this so it'll
be like that
wow that's pretty cool so it'll look
just like that
how is it are you harnessed it's like a
yeah it'll be like
a little thing that connects at my wrist
which like the way the
um aerialists have a connection
connected to your body your torso
somehow yeah it'll be connected
somewhere crotch
yeah hopefully like a nightmare
something yeah because when you get up
to like
minus you know 20 degrees or whatever
you
you'll be non-functional up there so
right you can't just rely
well you can't really rely on your hand
no i could no no
no no i was practic if i had to do this
up to like
you know two to three thousand feet i
could because holding on yeah
yeah you can a sand you can also do what
you know just put something around your
foot like the
the wires could come down okay so
something around your foot would just be
so just it takes
like i mean it's really hard to hang for
more than a couple of minutes
it's hard to hang for more than a minute
i think like the record is like two
minutes but
what with one second yeah with one hand
okay but this has to look
the whole that this has to look like the
one-handed advantage of the person
flying
it has to be exact so right you'd have
to have some freaky forearms
popeye yeah so i'll have assistance
built but
so i won't have a parachute or any of
that stuff that'll be above me so it'll
look really clean but i'll be
supported now if there's a balloon
failure or something like that
obviously i'm in trouble um obviously
but once i get the parachute on once i
get to 5 000
feet then we know okay he's not going to
die he has a parachute on
i can get away and now the big challenge
is how high can you go
so once you get how are you going to
know do you have an altimeter
on the i'll have an altimeter but i'm
also going to have a
communication okay full everything okay
i'm going to have cameras with me
are you using a watch for the altimeter
or like what are you using
i'm using this one called the kunu right
now but it's big sure no but i was
i've been jumping with suntoes and
things just to check
how accurate they are and they're not
bad they're like off by like 200 feet
or something like that but on the
landing you don't want to be off
you know especially if you're like me
you don't even you only have 400 jumps
not even right right so and you're
landing in dicey areas because you don't
know where you are
right so gust of wind can throw you here
or there
yeah anything but you also have to like
not hit a power line or a building or an
obstacle or anything wherever you are
right if you if you come down into a
mountain you're going to whack into that
it looks flat from here but if you
didn't adjust you're going to come in
hard and that's it you'll eat it right
if you hit a power line you're dead so
yeah those types of things we have to
like
and which is why when i'm controlling
the balloons and going up and up and up
and up and up
um i'm gonna
hopefully be fine hopefully you're
scaring the [ __ ] out of me already
so at 5000 feet you how do you get the
parachute
um it's up there and the balloons and
i'm going to pull it down
it's on like a fishing wire thing i pull
it down
and then i put it on that's the only
like really difficult thing as well
have you done this already you've
practiced that aspect i've practiced it
and that's like
really scary to everybody around oh like
they they're asking me why won't i just
wear the thing like everybody
yeah they're like you have to wear it
and you don't want to wear it and my
brother's really obsessed with it my
daughter's new question is how come
you're not wearing the parachute but um
but i'm telling her it's
fine but you haven't
have you done this transition yet where
you go from floating to putting the
parachute on
no that'll be done live the first time
oh
jesus this whole thing will be done the
first time live and i've never done it
in completion i've done all the elements
of it
so i've done the jumps i've done the
balloon flights i've flown the rig but
i've never put it all together that's
all going to happen for the first time
live on youtube
and so once you get the the vest on once
you get the
the parachute on then the goal is to see
how high you can get on yeah and once
that's the part that i'm obsessed with
when you get to the area of 30 000 plus
feet no no you can't cross there
i mean i i just want to get the goal is
i if i get up to like
25 000 feet i'm i'm excited okay
because that's where the ice i want to
disappear like i actually want the
visual to be that i disappear into the
sky
okay so you get up to 25. i'm not going
to kill myself
doing it hope not i won't okay i believe
but this one is
different than i'm gonna have the o2
things by the way you can't send the o2
pulse oximeter signals down so they
won't know if i'm hypoxic but i'm going
to have the o2 monitors in my pocket
i'm going to put them on i'm going to
show them to the camera they can still
communicate with you
yeah now if they can't that's a big
issue so if communication fails then
this is
for me communication is done through
what uh
rf this this incredible guy that builds
all of the communication for every
skydiving stunt movie so he's the same
way that a plane can communicate with
the ground
yeah yeah it's something yeah and i have
i have a transponder up here i have
everything so the planes
i'm visible everybody knows where i am
okay we're clearing everything with the
fa the atc
so everything is going to be you know
completely organized as it needs to be
we have a wind path in every location
that we're going to possibly do this in
of course new york is a dream and
there's some other dreams that we have
so
you know this is still we have a couple
of key points that we're
dreaming about doing this and uh
depending on wind and weather that's
where we'll do it and how do you get
how do you descend um
just let go of some you're just gonna
just completely just release myself yeah
so you're gonna skydive at 25 000 feet
yeah by the way when i did that when i
did the i told you when i did that uh
test when i went up to 20 almost 20 24 7
or whatever
i had the uh the helmet on the first
breath i took the entire thing was ice
right away so and i was flying down
looking through like a little hole
in the helmet yeah i couldn't see
jesus christ and so
when you land you have to land i mean
you're
from 25 000 feet you have to make sure
that you're conscious
you have to make sure that you can see
that's right but usually by the way even
if you are hypoxic
and you're dropping you clear up at like
ten thousand feet
so luke aikens the who you watch he did
a jump once
where he was jumping with felix
baumgarten who he trained
and he was um out of he was hypoxic he
was blacked out
but when he got to about 9000 feet or so
he woke up
and then from yeah but from 9000 feet
down you have you know 40 seconds to
figure out where you are and what you're
doing
okay
it still seems [ __ ] terrifying um
and so then you're you're floating down
and
you have to find a good spot to land and
when are you going to do this like
what's the the official launch date is
it
august 31 100 depending on winds
depending on when so if the winds are
[ __ ] on august 31st yeah
exactly and that's the other thing
youtube's been amazing on there it is
david blaine
ascension youtube originals august 31st
yeah that's basically what it is i love
that youtube stepped up to do this
but yeah it is amazing it is amazing
look at you floating above the cloud in
that image and that's
literally what you're going to be doing
yeah that's so [ __ ]
but also the thing about this one aside
from like the the technical part of it
is like
the visual on it so far is my favorite
one
yeah it's like up like when they did it
but when i look at the balloons i become
like giddy like and all these adults are
working we're all like laughing because
we're like little we're like
kids playing with balloon you know it's
like it's iconic it's something that
every kid has kind of thought of yeah
yeah grabbing a balloon and flying
like mary poppins yeah yeah yeah wow man
and that was my daughter's nickname when
she was growing up but we called uh
mary the real mary poppins if she was a
real very popular we'd put a balloon up
and we'd always watch it and dream and
talk about where it goes and stuff like
that
what is it like for her to when you
discuss things these things she's
so amazing i run ideas by her she's
amazing
yeah she's amazing by the way the reason
there's pink balloons in this one is
because i was showing her all the
balloons and she went is there going to
be pink
and i was like of course there's going
to be fake good now there's fake yeah
that's the lens wow
now you have you been doing live shows
this whole time or
are you are you able to with cope not
during covet no but
right up to code i was doing live and
that i i haven't been promoting
or anything but it's like my favorite
thing because i've been working on the
live
show for 20 some years and i've never
done one until
like the last few years like started
like
three years ago the first time i didn't
i which is crazy
right because yeah but i finally
felt like i had the right material to
make a good show
and the show is so it was it's so it's
like i open it with the mouse sewing
so the first thing is like but i bring
people up so it's also comical it's like
funny right like joking around and stuff
that you see people like ah yeah
when you say mouth sewing you actually
sew your mouth shut yeah
yeah and you do that how many nights a
week one uh
no so i so i would do two days on one
day off but every
day of a show means you can't eat for 36
hours before the show because i also
have to
put a gallon of water in my stomach i
have to put a cup of kerosene but now
i don't swallow the kerosene i put it in
my mouth now and spit it so i don't
swallow
but on jimmy uh jimmy kimmel i drank
this stuff and it's like
really really that's how the guy died
how glee that i told you
so now um i just put it in the mouth
spit it but see i and then i do the
frogs in the stomach i put the hanger
all the way down the throat to fetch
somebody's ring
i um i do the breath i do the breath
hold every single night and
um and then and then and then i have
them push an ice pick through my arm
every night
which is like you don't want to hit a
brachial you know anything a nerve
yeah or an artery or anything of course
so but i and i let them choose a spot
by the way i also brought the ice pick
if you do do want to see because i
i know that you know it's real but i
should if oh i believe it's real but i
still
want to see it i haven't done it i
haven't done it since my tour really
yeah are you itching to do it i mean i'd
like you to do it
i'd like you to do just to see that it
is like pretty straightforward
oh i believe it's straightforward but i
brought one with me and i got the
alcohol from them so here is uh
look at that girl poor girl and so
you're stitching
your mouth exactly but so see so what i
was able to do with the stage show is i
bring people up on stage and i have the
cameras with the big screen
so you see people reacting to this stuff
so it's the magic
plus the reaction so you get that whole
and this girl's really into it look at
her
so you you do this all the time
the stitching the mouth shut i would
imagine you would accumulate some scar
tissue no
that one's easy but this one's legit
this one i used to do it through the
hand this is the ice way
this one i used to do through the hand
and i developed so much scar tissue that
like when i move my fingers a certain
way i get a shooting pain so i stopped
doing my hands and i switched to here
that makes sense yeah i would i would
imagine that would really [ __ ] your
hands up
alcohol
so wait but so i might have to sit next
to you or something
do you want me to do this to you is this
what's going on here yeah i can come
over to your side
okay okay okay all right but wait don't
you need the
or you can put those on i'll just come
walk over
so should i take the thing off you can
if you like
we'll both be uh basically talking into
the same mic no but we can do it sitting
yeah but can you put those ones on yeah
okay
this mic work one second okay jamie will
turn this mic on and i'll crank this
thing over to here
okay so you choose the do you want the
left or the right
uh let's do the right since it's right
next to me
okay do you want them to come in and see
it as well no
okay good enough okay so now
this is not a new ice pick and usually i
do it with new ones which means
this isn't as sharp as it needs to be so
it means the push is going to be a
little more
difficult i guess why do you like to do
this you seem to be
or are these ones that you give us at
least pure alcohol yes
yes
i mean they're just the standard ones
that you get that's fine i'm sure
yeah yeah yeah oh you want to make sure
there's no scent in it or anything no no
i want to make sure that there's no
bacteria right but i mean on the alcohol
strip oh yeah exactly yeah um why do you
enjoy this you seem you're you're
excited about this no
well first of all it's amazing that you
can actually do something like this like
it's nothing so there's a guy named
miranda
can you pull up miranda you think so
miranda
it's this guy and nobody believed he was
doing it for real and he would take
rapiers and he would have them push
through
right through the middle of his body
through his lungs and everything he
would show on all sides and then they
would pull him out and he'd be perfectly
fine
he and every every doctor and saying oh
you can't do that but
so remember when steve irwin died do you
know why he died
no because he pulled the stingray thing
out of his heart the stingray
and he pulled it out right crocodile so
if he's
kept it in there he would have lived
right after that a 70 year old man was
on his boat and a stingray jumped up out
of the water
stung him in the heart and then stingray
was gone
but though i didn't even yeah oh my god
look at that
isn't that crazy but the fact that you
can actually do this
is what's crazy like the body can you
with your mind you can override it
and then the thing is he got so cocky
though that he thought he could do
anything
and then he ate one of these things he
swallowed it and he killed him he died
internally and died but see he got
really cocky because he was like i could
do anything that is [ __ ] insane so
he's
is he going through his liver he can go
through anything and that's what i'm
saying so the seven-year-old guy
that got the stingray to it stabbed him
in the heart
instead of pulling it out which it's
like a corkscrew
he waited till they with doctors till it
beat out the other side and he was
fine you see wow
so instead of pulling it out he waited
until what happened
the doctors waited with the heart they
let it beat out the other side and they
slowly let it come out it went through
his whole body
if they would have pulled it it's like a
corkscrew it would rip him apart
he would die how long did it take for it
to beat through no but i know that the
doctors what they did is they let it go
through
[Laughter]
guys
how many times this guy gets stabbed
like i've done that one by the way right
there
that's a safe place that's like not an
issue but when you go through the lungs
and stuff it's crazy
look it's crazy but this is too much i
wouldn't show it it's too like too much
[ __ ] sword man but that's what i'm
saying that one
listen but so what happened
was he started to get too cocky he
started to think he was fine
oh jesus christ
but okay so joe but you have to listen
to the origin of this trick though
that's not a trick no but i know but
listen the origin of this
is as a kid there's that trick where
they do needle through arm
yes right and it's like the rubber you
know the stuff and it sticks your skin
together
it looks perfect it looks like it's
really through your arm and then they
like squeeze blood out of the thing they
so i saw that and then i was like
but maybe that's like actually doable
like maybe that trick could really be
done
so like the same exact trick but for
real
right so that's this okay okay so you
take that
okay like i said it's going to be a
little tricky to push through just
because the
it's usually sharp and this time it's
not as sharp but how do you know where
to do it
we're gonna pick there's no particular
spot
you know you're gonna how do i know i'm
not gonna hit an artery though i don't
know i can't kill you bro
so you want me just right here anywhere
sure what's where do you prefer
wherever you want like right there wow
sure i don't know but
yeah do it there where you want do it
where you want when you say well
sure like where do you like it to go
through the bottom
no i liked where you were going right
like you're you're too i mean that's
that's fine like so you have to go like
through
well what do you want me to do yeah
you're gonna push through okay
so hold on you here yeah keep like a
straight path
okay like that no it goes straight like
that yeah i'd go
straight through yeah okay ready slowly
and go slow
you're lifting my see that yep see
so it's hard to believe that it's real
keep pushing
keep going keep going
wait uh oh hold on
what happened i hit a nerve oh jesus
no no no no no no no come on man you got
to do another spot you were hitting the
nerve
yeah but what if i [ __ ] your arm up
man and then you can't hang from the
balloon and then youtube's mad at me
[Laughter]
okay again jesus bro
okay so by the way honest to god
i'm never go in this direction which way
to go i always go
this direction from inside to out i'm
just saying of like the
of the all the times i did it i've
always gone this direction do you want
me to go that direction
i'm just telling you i've never
experienced that better no so what's the
difference i'm just saying i've never
done it this way oh okay so it's the
groundbreaking
no i'm saying it's nuts well it's
definitely nuts
okay good no but from the bottom like
this like that
yeah and then i go again and i would i
would try to go like a straight path
through like right there
no i would go like lower and in like
just right there
ready yeah okay yeah i'd like that and
keep hold on
wait wait push
yeah like that like that that's good
yep we're on a clean path we hit
something but it's fine
now what i use is this i use the skin
here and i push so you can see it come
through
push that's it see alrighty
super unnecessary but uh but it does
seem like a magic trick like it
definitely doesn't seem like a magic
trick
but hold on there's blood vessels and
everything yeah there's no blood
well it's a very small hole in
comparison to
it now it's a good sign there is blood
on the other hole
oh okay yeah that's because it's it's
that you hit something
and your body is healthy so it's
clotting out pretty quickly
okay all right should i put it out yeah
okay here we go slowly
go ahead pull pull
and that's it okay
so here this is for you to keep
i can't say i enjoyed that that was very
uncomfortable
but what's weird to me more than
anything is that you
seem to enjoy it you enjoyed the freak
out part of it
no i i like what i said i like that you
can override your body with your brain
to do things that
seem like they're not real yeah it
doesn't see
you know it's real because of what you
do to your body but most people see all
the things they're doing think it's a
magic trick
right they think it's a trick like okay
it's a trick like he's not holding his
breath
and you've done that thing with a sword
well you've gone through your body
yeah but it was not very thick and it
was through right here i didn't go
okay she didn't go through the organs
like this guy did no but i
but i think you can oh well obviously he
did it right
and swallowing this is what killed him
so
he got really he thought he could do
anything yeah
so he's like i'm gonna swallow this type
of thing and then i'm gonna bring it up
he swallowed it and he couldn't bring it
up and then he fell asleep and it
ruptured his heart
died he woke up they found him cold oh
boy
internal bleeding jesus christ
that is the thing about these extreme
feats right is that you
you possibly might be pushing the
boundaries of what's physically possible
which means you could die like houdini
like houdini died from getting punched
yeah in the stomach yeah
how does a punch to the stomach kill you
well so normally
like i had kimbo slice punching the
stomach did you really yeah
ouch yeah and then he i had him do it
again
and then i felt bad i didn't want to
make him keep doing it because it wasn't
you know right
because you as you know you can train to
take a punch that's yes obviously
so i basically had my trainer rich
beretta throw
heavy balls kick me in the stomach do
everything and i trained for
a long like a year just to take a punch
from anybody and
oh yeah comes kimbo boom oh and then i
was like
and then i said to him do it again so
and by the way i'm not even in top
physical so i said do it again and then
i but i could have obviously could have
kept going so
boom and i did that based on houdini
right right so
but here's the thing so houdini would do
this on stage every night and it's a
it's a great thing in the show it's like
look every any ten strongest people in
he's come punch him and uh so the and
these kids think he's invisible
invincible right like he could like this
is houdini man of steel whatever right
so he's sleeping in his dressing room
these two college kids one kid's like
watch out strong
and they punch houdini in the stomach
really while he's asleep yes
and as you know that's dangerous because
you don't have a wall up so
he ruptured something but he's a
workaholic so the guy is
in a lot of pain whether he might maybe
it wasn't related maybe it's something
different maybe he had
you know panda who knows right he's in a
lot of pain but he wouldn't let the
audience down
so he wouldn't quit his show so he did
his showing at the end of show he's
upside down in the water tank everything
else when he shouldn't have been
he should have been in the hospital but
instead he did the show that night
collapsed
on the stage was not from the water tank
but right after the water tank was
rushed to a hospital and then died in
the hospital
and what was the diagnosis what did he
die from well it was you know 1926 right
little
voodoo they died from voodoo
[Laughter]
yeah wow so when you
i mean that that's the thing about
someone who does
something that pushes it to the edge
like that i mean when someone sees you
hold your breath for 20 minutes what's
fascinating about is not just that it's
hard to do
but that you might die yeah
right yeah yeah or some people say oh
what
what's how's he doing right what's the
trigger you know so there's all
different
interpretations but the the worry the
thing that thrills people yeah it's like
the
you know that well yeah the the idea
that something could go wrong that's why
everybody watched the evil knievel
because he might
and he often did wipe out the spike yeah
yeah
what do you this thrill of getting to
that edge
is very dangerous right because you keep
pushing there's a danger but i feel like
if you rehearse and practice and
put the best team and don't just do
crazy things without like a plan
then i feel like the danger is like sure
the danger's there but i also rode my
motorcycle here
which is also extraordinary i've lost a
lot of friends on bikes yeah
right so sure i get what you're saying
and i i understand all that
you seem to like thrills
well i mean i like adventures like
riding a motorcycle trailer
adventure that is an adventure yeah it's
i i mean i look at people that do it
every day and i go that's a braver
california you're allowed to like weave
dudes so that's
that's kind of amazing in california
like go ahead
give it a shot [ __ ] it you're here you
know
how where do you see this do you have
like a
grand vision of your life in terms of
like these stunts that you do
like do you have like some ultimate
threshold that you'd like to get to
wait we have to take a break i want to
make sure that i'm okay
okay hold on are you bleeding yeah yeah
we'll take a break we'll be right back
so we got to clean up your wound yeah
it was fine yeah you're you seem to
enjoy it
you really do you you were laughing
while they were cleaning it up and
checking it and you're like it's good
we're good
it was just uh what was it the blood
what was it that was bothering you
he's drinking all the water to prepare
for swallowing a frog i just felt uh you
know
too much uh of the magic becoming real
it's the magic how much water do you
have to drink
uh well probably to do what you want to
do well we'll see
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
what's up how do you have to drink it at
a certain speed because i've seen people
that can chug these they just shove the
whole thing down their face
it's almost like a magic chicken itself
they can drink it yeah those guys are
just
i had like the guy that was the fastest
work on it with me but
how many do you have to drink um you've
drank
three so far yeah plus the two out there
but yeah
so fives you have to drink eight total
do you need a bucket or anything to
throw the frog up in
do we have a bucket ice bucket
that doesn't seem like enough fluid
though bucket cam
there's a american flag bucket in the
back that big one
oh perfect oh look at that how
convenient
this poor frog has no idea because he's
a magical frog how do you know he's real
hmm he's real well you don't know that
could be a magic trick
well if it is it's uh
amazing you should sell these to people
that don't want biological frogs because
that's a [ __ ] live frog
i mean he's looking at me he's moving
around he's bobbing his head
he's trying to get the [ __ ] out he's
making the thing with the throat
look at him he's trying to get out
that's a real frog kids
no doubt
when did you uh start doing this the
frog thing
is that enough
what if it overflows there's a guy
there was a guy called the human
aquarium and
so the thing about most of the acts that
i'm doing by the way like
night after night usually the people
that did them it was like they're one
act so there's one guy called the human
aquarium and he was a guy that could
swallow frogs and bring them up but he
would do it you'd see him swallow them
and then you'd see him bring them up so
it wasn't magical it was like a skill
set
i would usually what i'd do is i'd put
them in my stomach keep them in there
for like two hours and then bring them
up and freak you out
right and i'd have a gallon of water in
my stomach so i have an aquarium
that baking soda gets rid of the acid no
food 36 hours
and then once i drink this we're at
a gallon or four liters so just under a
go so
so did you not eat for 36 hours in
preparation for this yes
that's a lot of not eating for this
poor frog's worst moment of his life
this poor little dude jaime just in case
you don't think he's real
he's real he's real oh there's more than
one in there no that's just him
it's just an i illusion
there was a little one in there that's a
decent-sized frog too by the way
you wouldn't want to swallow a frog that
large
mark twain has a quote he says eat a
live frog first thing in the morning and
nothing worse can happen for the rest of
your day
by the way back to the james nestor book
the one you're saying deep
or something he talks about that's
really amazing which is in
one of my favorite parts in there he
talks about how coral communicates
can i read this thing okay yeah sure
so he talks about it's one of my
favorite things
um that he talks about it's so amazing
so let's see we're deep
okay so
i have like a bunch of notes
what app are you using to read from uh
ibooks just because you could keep all
the books there
and you highlight things yeah with
ibooks yeah of course
i didn't know you could have oh yeah
yeah yeah and then you keep all of your
books here
right oh no i do that on my phone but i
didn't know you could highlight
i rarely read on the phone too i usually
use a kindle
yeah i don't i only use this is the
thing i like live by so it's like ruined
my life but also
also had it helped it somehow i guess
some way
let's see hold on it'll take me a second
to
pull it up i just like the kindle
because it looks like paper
you know the paper white ones yeah and
they're yeah and they're easier on the
eyes
yeah tricky on the eyes as well
okay so can i just read it yeah yeah
okay so it's part of what the aquanauts
and aquarius are trying to find out
they're also trying to crack
the more mystical marine riddles like
the secret behind
coral's telepathic communication
this is so crazy when you write to it
every year
on the same day at the same hour usually
within the same minute
corals of the same species although
separated by
thousands of miles will suddenly spawn
in
perfect synchronicity the dates
and times vary from year to year for
reasons only the coral knows
stranger still while one species of
coral spawns during one hour
another species right next to it waits
for a different
hour or a different day or a different
week before spawning and synchronicity
with its own species
distance seems to have no effect if you
broke off a chunk of coral and placed it
in a bucket beneath a sink in london
that chunk would in most cases spawn at
the same time as
other coral of the same species around
the world
which is crazy like you could take a
piece of coral
break it off put it in london and
another coral the same species will in
synchronicity spawn at the exact same
time
they have no idea why the synchronous
spawn is essential for coral survival
coral colonies must continuously expand
outward to thrive
expand outward to thrive to remain
healthy and strong they must breed
outside of their gene pool with
neighboring colonies
once released to the surface the coral
sperm and eggs have only about 30
minutes to fuse
any longer any longer and the coral eggs
and sperm will either dissipate or die
off
researchers have found that if the
spawning is just 15 minutes out of sync
coral colony's chances of survival are
greatly reduced
coral is the largest biological
structure on the planet and covers 175
000 square miles of the sea floor and it
can communicate
in a way far more sophisticated than
anyone ever
thought and yet coral is one of the most
primitive
animals on earth coral has no eyes no
ears and no brain
is that crazy that's insane yeah that's
what i thought it was
well it's fascinating too that you just
have no idea why or how
i mean what is the what's the mechanism
for their communication
the fact that if something's under a
sink in london it
syncs up with coral the same species on
another side of the planet like what is
it i think like one of the most
futuristic minds of our lifestyle
is jim cameron i think like avatar
and terminator 2 and like the machines
taking
like i think we're going to look back
and be like wow
he really predicted a lot he knew some
[ __ ]
the trees all communicating with each
other yeah yeah
well you've have you read about the
mycelium and
the the fungus underneath the soil
that actually the the trees utilize it
through their root structures and they
communicate through that
yeah there's some sort of a there's some
sort of a mycorrhizal relationship that
fungus has with with these trees and
they they actually somehow or another
communicate through each other as well
they're like
using the soil like this that's crazy
yeah we think of soil as being
dirt right just but it's there's life in
there yeah yeah all sorts of
biological life living in that soil yes
and these
trees and different plants actually
through their root structure communicate
and use the use the the fungi that live
in the soil and it's very very paul
stamets who's a
wizard when it comes to mycology and and
talking about fungus and
he's got some amazing work that he's
done just his whole life
studying mushrooms it's like so advanced
when he talks to you about it like you
you just really get this feeling like
there's something going on that we don't
totally understand
like the largest animal but fungus is
kind of an
animal it breathes oxygen and it
breathes out carbon dioxide
so the the crate is crazy yeah so the
relationship that fungus
that mushrooms have with the earth is in
some ways
more similar to us than it is to plants
because plants are breathing in carbon
dioxide obviously and breathing out
oxygen
so the functions are closer to function
yeah then they're living with these
things and there's
uh a group of fungi
i guess in the pacific northwest that's
the largest
living creature other than i guess like
biological organism you'd say was a
coral reef but there's something in the
pacific northwest that's
[ __ ] enormous and it's just one
interconnected mushroom structure
wow it's very heavy yeah and obviously
the right ones can bring you to god the
right ones can connect you
to alien life and yeah you know the
future and
tell you what you're doing wrong with
the planet yeah yeah so there's some
there's something going on with these
things into a different part of your
consciousness well we're just very
egocentric and arrogant in our ideas
about what the human race means to the
rest of the planet because we have this
ability to manipulate things and send
texts and emails
it's just about our proportions
basically just because our fingers and
our ability to like
yeah but we think that's so important
because it's so important to us because
it's so significant
like the ability to watch a television
show or not be able to the ability to
fly in a plane or not
those things are so significant that we
think of them as being the most
significant things in the world
but meanwhile there's some animals like
like when you see a flock of birds
fly in synchronicity in some sort of
strange
dance and you're like how the [ __ ] are
they doing that
and no one knows they really don't know
there's all this guesswork
they're not really sure exactly what's
going on how do they know how to travel
thousands of miles every season and go
back to the place where they spawned
like they don't know they don't know
like how does salmon
salmon figure out a way to get all the
way back to where they were born
they they make their way all the way
through the river to the ocean
and then when it's time to rock and roll
they get all the way back and they have
to get back to that one spot they can't
get
just any old river they won't they won't
make it they won't survive they won't
spawn they won't do it
they have to get back to the place where
they belong and something in their
little salmon brains
are in their salmon biological system no
and we don't know what it is
we don't know what it is but we [ __ ] up
and we damn these river structures
and then they die and they die off the
pacific northwest has it
they had a huge problem with that and
they did they didn't understand it when
they first put these dams in place these
salmon would just
pool up and they try to redistribute
them to other places and then they're
like nope
i need to go back to where i'm from it's
weird man biological life
is weird and amazing it is amazing and
it's funny right like
we think we're so because we can do
things that other ones can't do but they
can do things we can't do
yeah we just don't put a high priority
on what they can do
yeah for whatever ego centric reason
yeah but i was
i was like i was swimming in a tonga
in the pacific northwest and uh it was
it was with humpback whales
and i was with my daughter and we looked
at the mother
and the calf you know i mean you know
swimming we were watching them
and um it was it's it's the most
beautiful
overwhelming moment i i'll show you
after uh some footage
but um then i was alone
and i was like holding my breath and
kind of free diving next to them
and and you know when you're not on
scuba it's not
they're happy to be around you and um
free diving and swimming with the mother
and the baby
and i'm looking at the mother and i'm
certain
certain that she's just looking at me
but in the nicest way
like in the most peaceful it was just
it's not like a shark
eye that's like whoa this thing is like
you know
so i'm like certain that she's like
being trying to communicate something
like that saying i'm still on the same
breath
i'm communicating and i i go like this i
open my arms up and turn
to the mother like this or something i
go like that
and the mother mimics the the humpback
mimics me
and turns right towards me and goes like
this right so now we're swimming
together
and i'm like this like kicking at fins
on and
the the humpback is doing the mother is
doing that to me and i'm swimming
in synchronicity with with the mother
and and the babies following her
and then as soon as i'm like done from
here and i go back down
she goes back down and it was like i
wanted to cry
but yeah it's like you think like
something but also their brains are so
much bigger than our of course they're
so
yeah i still have all this water in my
stomach so if i'm gonna do this i might
let's do it so
you need another one of those what is
the reason why you need
so much water to do this is it so that
the frog has a place to be
so the frog is safe you know i've never
injured a frog or anything
i'm sure he feels very comfortable
knowing that here he goes
oh jesus did he hop right out yeah
he's like i know what the [ __ ] is
happening here oh hey buddy
hold on let me just okay so okay i just
usually like to give him a little get
him a little bath oh yeah
good okay so this is basically the
technique and i've put
up to 10 frogs inside look so i could
come
anymore
and now we could hang and talk for you
know as long as so how long does he stay
in there
um what's the lungs you've kept them in
there and they live like
three hours or so and none of them have
ever died nope
wow that's pretty mean how bad you have
to pee right now
on a one to ten
anytime anybody complains about needing
to pee i'm going to show them this video
10th tenth water and what are they eight
ounces
sixteen
it's more than a gallon of water yeah
now it's the magical parts i got
mouth empty
then i have to like get him to swim up
to the
how do you do that i don't know
i just like did it and had fluoroscopies
and looked where they were
and then saw that then and figured out
how to sort i did sword swamp
it's like
do you feel them moving around inside
you when there's a lot
when there's 10
jamie your face here he comes
no no i got it no first i like to get a
little bit of
you forcing them out now you can't talk
just get some more water
when's the first time you did this one
um i i worked on it i started like
three or four years ago and it's been uh
you know it's the first time you put the
frog in your mouth i got that
no i didn't swallow the first thing i
just wanted to get comfortable with the
food
salmonella yeah and then i got it again
after i tried it the second time
and then i built up a resistance to
salmonella
i hope it makes that's good if you like
sushi
mouth empty right
here he comes
this is obazar here it comes
it's because i drank so much so it's
like
i have to like locate them you have to
locate it kind of
the sound would you call this jamie asmr
this is so strange
so for people that are just listening i
highly recommend you go to the video
because you're gonna have to no no
no no no we're going to keep this up
exactly the way it is
people need to say oh
take out like a liter of water
oh my god so strange
oh i spit on biggie
it's called the water spout that's how i
usually put out the fire
oh my god
hold on
the frog is probably like what the [ __ ]
did i do deserve this
i bet that frog was just like an [ __ ]
person in another life
that's a gallon of water do we need
another bucket
maybe go get that plastic bucket in the
back
i don't know if that's good enough but
for now we'll just use that for now
it is uh quite preposterous to watch the
amount of water that's coming out of you
oh it's just good better
where is he at right now
boy
you got him in there put him in my hands
okay
there he is oh boy
here little fella little fella you've
had a rough life
you're not a road you've had a road
buddy
so that's the frog trick he's alive
and perfect yeah he seems fine don't
lose him
i don't want to lose him hey you want to
put him back in the jar
hold up let's get some a little bit of
water
fresh
okay
i think i'm gonna need more than paper
towels jamie
yeah i'm gonna wash my hands eventually
oh there is handcuffs here
oh you have a pair yeah jamie real ones
i don't know but is that just
coincidental
no no no there's a guy uh ed calderon
he's uh
a guy who used to uh work with the
mexican police at the border
may take a few paper towels too and he
uh
he brought us some handcuffs to teach us
how to get out of them right
just noticed that they were there random
that seems planned yeah but that's
really they were just here
well he gave him to me and uh he gave me
like a little tool
to show me how to uh yeah how to open
them
what's this plastic thing i have no idea
but he gave you tools to show you how to
open them like cow
i don't remember i have to go back and
watch the video if you ever get
handcuffed yeah how they get the [ __ ]
out of the show like how to pick on me
how to shove it through the thing to
kind of like
go past the teeth of the lock to make it
open up so i had to pick them
yes exactly
is it not going to work i don't know
what are you trying to do there
so let's see like
what are you physically trying to do oh
i just want to see if i can actually
break them break them yeah like break
the metal
so like really break them for real
how do you usually do that i don't know
you don't know
no it's like really hard to break that
was it usually easy to break them no
it's always
very difficult to break handcuffs
because you're breaking the handcuffs
right but you're trying yeah
because there's some sort of technique
to it or something using leverage
that's what i'm hoping
how many days of your life do you think
you've spent [ __ ] with handcuffs you
could just
boil it all down to time
50.
yeah this is probably boring for like
anybody that's that they
so you're just trying to use the way the
attachment
as a leverage point yellow thing yeah
that thing might be weird that yellow
thing but
yeah i'm trying to use like uh
it's like what is the yellow thing how
do we know
oh this is just how ed brought him to us
yeah i don't know if i can get these
things broken
hmm you want to keep we could keep
talking like now i'm like
going to be stuck on this yeah but
you'll be so preoccupied
yeah that frog's like what the [ __ ] just
happened
look at him he's just sitting there
breathing
yeah imagine them being a frog you're
like well this is it
i knew it was coming one day that's why
i'm so scared of bass
by the way they're yeah these are the
the ones i get are like
normally they would be like used for
bait you know sorry
first i asked the guys i could give me
some beer
and uh they became my daughter's pets
i've never never ever injured or
heard a frog ever but how did you know
that that was gonna be the case when you
first swallowed one
the first one you swallowed you probably
had to be like no i didn't start the
fire it started with like bingo balls
and things like that i would put inside
come out
i started playing around so it started
with like you know
um how much water could i put in then
how could i spout the water out to use
it to put out the fire then could the
kerosene float on top then i went to
be so bad for what is kerosene like
inside your body do you feel it burning
no but like the problem is all that's no
the problem is all that stuff has a
residue
what does this guy do in general it's
oil based this is the kerosene
it's water spout thing [ __ ] ali egyptian
fire eater and human fountain
do you know of this guy yeah that's the
guy i'm talking about oh there he is
there it is
yeah he's an old boy there's a really
funny clip of see he's spitting the
kerosene and then he puts it out with
the water which is underneath because it
floats on top
yeah look how much control he has i saw
that act and wanted to like figure that
out
what year is this did it um like
almost a hundred days 1925. this is
almost done almost a hundred years ago
i mean that guy yeah he was called the
human fire hydra
that had to be a rough way to go however
he died
because he probably did that every day
oh
so let me get back to the question that
i had before you ran off because you got
you were worried about your arm
do you do you have like you've done
so many insane stunts and so many
really of these uh bizarre things
that require so much of you do you do
you like
have a thing in your mind that you have
to keep ramping it up and that do you
have
a place that you would ultimately like
to get to with me
with these things no i just constantly
like kind of try to figure out like
what things have been done in the past
historically and then i try to figure
out how to make them interesting and
then i figure out how to make them
kind of modern so it's it's not like uh
you know it's like it's a it's a small
step-by-step process and i think about
each thing
and then i try to put them all together
do you feel like you have to keep
pushing the envelope
um well i have like a few things that
i've been
trying to work on to get to that place
so
there is like a it's not a push the
envelope it's just i have a bunch of
things i've been trying to
how many do you have like on the back
burner in the back your head
i have two more crazy ones that i'm
trying can you share them
uh
i the the thing i will tell you is that
if you put them all together the the
letters
all equal out like my name so that
[Laughter]
and that's yeah that's all you can say
but yeah i
think that's i don't want to go too into
it
what do you what do you enjoy most do
you enjoy i feel like if you talk about
something too much and
then you talk it away i understand yeah
yeah you take away the magic of like
what he's getting
he's gonna do what yeah like when it
gets announced yeah
yeah do you enjoy doing these big things
or do you enjoy the live shows or do you
enjoy
freaking people just random people out
there like
all of it like so it's not like one
specific thing i kind of love doing card
tricks i love doing magic i love doing
things from history i love looking
like the the human aquarium guy uh you
know the the frogs and goldfishes some
of that came from houdini writing and
miracle mongers all about his act so
it's like
you look into the history of things that
have been done like [ __ ] ali the human
fire hydrant
and you find these there's a great book
that ricky j wrote who is an amazing
magician where he discusses and explains
everything you learn all these things
put them together
and then what i do that ricky thought
was amazing is
and insane is like actually take these
ideas
that that seem impossible but magical
and that's what the amazing part is
taking them from a
hypothetical image and then learning how
to do them so that's like what's amazing
about the whole
process to me and ricky's book called
learning pigs and farpo
there's so many bizarre but amazing acts
that exist in there so it's like you
look at them like
no that can't be real but it was real if
you believe it was real
how many of their how many of you are
there out there
like this must be of like i always think
of stand-up comedians as being a very
small
group of people that kind of only
understand each other there's a good
amount of
amazing magicians how many
a thousand on the planet
no there's a lot of guys that are at me
yeah and there's different categories
but the stuff that you're doing is not
just magic what i'm saying is like
this sort of like the crazy bizarre like
you're mixing at all
you're transcending magic into you go
into this weird realm of what
i like all these videos i like to use
the body as the prop
so i like to figure out how to do things
where like your body is magic and i
think that comes from like i didn't have
like you know a lot of many resources to
like oh go get which is lucky because
then i was like okay so what can i do
with like what's around okay an ice pick
or a bunch of water or of course you'd
be industrious
yeah yeah not again but like you have to
figure it out
but you also have do you balance it out
with like i mean you obviously
develop some problems from not eating at
one time
and you know you've you've got these
stunts where
they have this possibility of physically
injuring you
permanently yeah yeah sorry
the risks and the rewards yeah there's
not that many of those people out there
i hope not no that's what i'm saying
like the people i wouldn't worry about
them
but you don't worry about yourself well
i think i'm careful
you know yeah i'm still like
so we did one two three four five six
seven eight nine
ten ten five five liters basically so
that's like
a i think that's
in one shot i think that's a record i
don't think i've actually ever done that
many you never drank that much water
i don't think so i think i usually cap
it a gallon
well it's dangerous right you can die
from drinking too much water water
intoxication yes
yeah but i think that's if you like
flush it out too much but
but when you combine that with other
things then it's dangerous so that's
what kids have done like in the like for
tor
fraternity when they have to do those
hazing rituals
right they've died from drinking too
much water and there was a woman in
san jose yeah it is possible of course
it was san jose where she was on the
radio
and there was a thing like how much
water can you drink and she wanted to
win an xbox for a kid and she died
yeah yeah i think that's when your
electrolyte levels get messed up is that
when your heart stops working yeah
because
yeah so you your water becomes just too
much water in your system
and your body doesn't know what to do
with it and yeah that makes sense yeah
yeah and it flushes out and
to puts the imbalance off on your
electrolytes so when you do something
like this do you make sure that you you
consume a lot of electrolytes
beforehand because i couldn't eat or do
anything if you're going to do the frog
and why is my friend told my friend told
me do not do the frog out here
sounds gross i don't want you to have to
do that because i'm gonna have to listen
to it
it definitely does sound gross but
you you feel okay after drinking all
that water that quickly yeah but i
spouted it out
that's true most of it right there's got
to be a lot more inches on purpose
yeah jesus you're
a weird man david blaine you really are
that's what i was getting at like what
i'm saying there's not a lot of people
like you out there i'm glad you're there
i really am i'm glad you're out there
first of all because i think you're very
entertaining but also because
i i love when there's a new type of
person that i meet
you know and you're there's not i've met
a lot of people but you're you're in
this new like oh
and then there's this guy you know this
is like a totally new frequency of human
or just freak take out the quincy
both but i mean it's
it's a a very strange path that you're
on
i mean ultimately it's like at the end
of the day it's it's
trying to just figure out how to make
things that seem
as as close to magic as possible and the
process is really
difficult and tricky and laborious to
get to
but eventually you start to figure oh
this could look magical what's this or
this could you know but you seem like a
very
joyful person because of all this you
you clearly
love what you do yeah yeah yeah look at
that you sparked that
yeah yeah that's why i do it no you love
it
yeah that's what's interesting it's like
such a strange thing to love to do
stand no it's crazy you
fight take care down a long time but
that but i'm saying that's
crazy like it is maybe but that's the
same
it's the same you're pushing your body
to do things that
most people but you're basically you're
living in a place where
you have to override discomfort and you
have to override what your body's trying
to tell you not to do and you push
yourself
you know it's and then and it's that
whole journey of pushing yourself to do
things that you
physically don't think you can do or to
set a goal
that that's the best part i think i i'm
just
i'm fascinated by people that are really
far down on a path
that seems really dan you have we ever
brought up that woman stephanie
millinger
on the podcast before i follow her on
instagram and i know i've posted some
some of her stuff on instagram but she's
like a contortionist and um
she has like an incredible balance and
and and core strength
and she's this very small woman who does
insane things with her body
like she did this one she's on a
handstand and she
bends her back so that her butt touches
her head
like her spine is so flexible that you
look at some of the things that she does
and
they don't seem to be like watch this
look at this
yeah watch how she does this and look
and also she's
balancing on these posts right so but
look what she does with her back wow
look at that that is amazing amazing
yeah and then she stands with one hand
and she does by the way she does this
like off the side of cliffs and she's
incredible like look at the
way her body is contorting yeah that's
incredible she's
pressing her butt against the top of her
head
in the craziest way like it doesn't seem
like a person should be able to do that
and the amount of physical strength that
it takes to move your body like this
and balance while you're doing it it's
just it's
the the years
yeah this is what i'm saying like she's
so far
down the path see if you can find the
one where she bounces on the plates that
one the middle
where you see the the plate watch this
so she takes a
this is like a standard olympic
weightlifting plate right
so she puts it down so it's on its edge
and then she stands it on top of a bar
right so you got this like this bar that
was it's like a
like a small chin balancing yeah so it's
a round thing bouncing on another round
thing
it's amazing and then she lifts her
whole body
all the way up and over and does a
handstand on this [ __ ] thing
i mean she's amazing it's
and again always smiling always like
joyful loves loves this but the physical
strength that it takes to do something
like that and the kind of balance
that's what i'm talking about like
someone who's on this crazy path
where if you you asked someone could
someone do that you'd be like no
but your body doesn't do work like that
that's not how body works but it
does you just have to take these little
baby steps for
years and then you look back and you're
in a different place and then also you
find a version of it and then you figure
out how to make it your own yes she's
like taken something and then made it
like a whole
yes new art right poetic
yeah yeah she's or like cirque du soleil
like when every time i go to see
i've seen most of the cirque du soleil
shows every time i go i'm like what the
f
how the [ __ ] is that what do they do
what are they they're aliens
like yeah but they're on a path they're
just really
far down on this path of extreme
dedication
extreme focus and that's what you're
doing you're just doing it with
bizarre physical feats and magic it's
very interesting
it's very interesting i'm really happy
that you're around
i really am i enjoy the fact that a
person like you exists
oh thank you and uh i want to thank you
for being here too man i really enjoyed
the [ __ ] out of it it's very cool
very cool to talk to you too wanting to
meet you for a long time oh my pleasure
thank you my honor thank you very much
thank you so one more time this will
most
likely be taking place august 31st
whether it's
we will let everybody know we'll put it
on instagram we'll put it on twitter and
if there's any sort of a change let me
know and we'll let everybody know
great thank you brother appreciate you
man goodbye everybody